okay
what's up guys it's your man donovan
sharp i'm just kidding
hello everybody it's torsha tori welcome
to my channel in today's episode we have
just pearly things
hey hey what's up
you can look to this camera oh that's
the camera i look at you're so funny um
so in today's episode i'm gonna grill
her in the seat we're gonna do the roast
i'm just kidding i'm totally getting
excited i'll roast you a little bit not
hard not hard though i'm a lady and
it sucks to be in the manosphere as a
woman can you agree
pros and cons you get you get a lot of
sims right no you know i don't allow
simping on my channel you control but no
sense but you also get a lot of like
they don't symptom
anger i guess sometimes but
that's that i'm okay with that's like
that i would rather men
express their rage at me
then go do something on some random
girl's uh profile and then them get it
blasted on right you can't
so you can't really complain too much
well i'd rather the men
who i like even if they're mean to me i
do care about
men in general and so i'd rather them
embarrass themselves on my channel get
rid of it if they need me to then get
blasted on some random girl who's going
to be like look at this misogynist you
know what i'm saying sorry i'm not
looking at you
over here that's okay
i don't know what name one horrible
thing about the manosphere that you wish
was different or you don't agree with
one
um
i don't agree with
the like cheating like high value men
have the right to cheat i like your
opinion on this um do tell
i
i don't think you have a right to cheat
on anyone and i think that if you want
to like make an arrangement with a girl
that's okay with it that's fine but the
whole like i can cheat as long as you
don't find out it's cool that's i don't
know that's i would be okay with that
yeah um what if you didn't know though
if i didn't know yeah
um
you know that philosophy thing i talk
about this so much it's not one that
comes to mind it's like if a tree went
down in a forest and you weren't there
did it make a sound it's like well
we know that when big things fall
it will likely make a sound right
so when it comes to cheating if you
don't know can you be mad it's like no
but i would hope they don't do it you
know what i'm saying but that's why i'm
always saying like the inkling thing i'm
like if oh if i [ __ ] find out excuse
my language then now i'm insecure
even though i should have been it's it's
more of an honesty thing why why because
to me character is important and your
values are important yeah so
to me it's dishonest to the person that
you love more than anyone else in the
world that you want to spend the rest of
your life with yeah that you're lying to
them
do
i agree with you i see your point
however do you think most women can
handle the truth
honestly um
no
so
either either find a girl that would
which there's a lot of girls that will
beyonce
there's a lot of people that aren't
getting laid pearl and you know it what
do you mean there are a lot of men that
aren't getting matched up that's a
problem right yeah that's a problem i
hate that i can't wait
what does that have to do with cheating
so for you're saying that they should
find somebody that doesn't cheat oh
you're saying the girl find the guy well
i'm saying
do what works for you if
having your guy cheating you don't care
if you don't find out that's fine right
but i just think that in a partner that
i would look for like values and
character is important and i wouldn't
want to be with somebody that cheats
because
essentially you're lying to the person
that you want to spend the rest of your
life with i see what you're saying yeah
like guys omission is a form of lying i
googled it
just so we're clear like because people
tried to call cap on that on me and i
was like no omission's actually a lie so
i agree with that
um but i mean i i can't deny more high
value men are going to cheat duh yeah
than the average regular person
but a lot of times the manosphere just
acts like character isn't there and so
any guy given the opportunity is going
to do it
um and i just disagree with that because
what would you define as character
so we're on the show like in this case
it's telling the truth even when it's
hard okay i'm gonna google it for us
because i don't know i'm not trying to
like no you're okay
i'm like hoping that's why it is
the men okay moral the mental and moral
qualities distinctive to an individual
a person in a novel play or movie okay
whatever that's like a character
character well i think a lot of times
the man of sphere they what they're
talking about
is women
wrecking their homes
over you know one instance and like not
even trying to work through it
i yeah they try to put it off like the
cheating doesn't hurt women
if she's leaving a marriage guys
it's an issue
but
a man
would she different though i agree with
that i know i just i really want to
argue that one i don't like that one
but i i'm i think we're minorities and
this one to be honest with you we can be
pygmies and [ __ ] but i i don't think
sorry i don't think that we're
like most women i really don't i think
that if most women given the opportunity
if they were like this man cheated on me
i can do better i think they would be
delusional to think that
like at a certain age like they think
that they're so much better than the
dad
and you and i both agree that unless
there's abuse or is that just me
unless there's abuse in the home
right
we like the parents to stay together i'm
talking like
like i my parents screamed at each other
my mother had mental illness we've
talked about this
i think i would be
so
much worse
not saying that like i'm awful but if my
parents didn't stay together i think i
would have commitment issues for sure
yeah i i think once you have kids it's
not about your feelings anymore thank
you yeah once once you have kids it's
not about you ladies stop thinking
that like that bothers me is there like
adele for instance she's like i had to
do what made me happy and made a whole
album on it yeah dude
and it's like i get that
but
i get it and i know it's so
controversial nowadays with feminism and
the moms are like you need to be
whatever and it's like but no it's not
about you
your decision in this moment that you
might even that you will regret let's be
honest most women regret i don't know
the stat but they wish that they didn't
because they end up single can somebody
get the stat and put that in the chat
but it's like why break up the home
for like when you'll get over it you
know what i'm saying i can't even think
of it i just the hard thing with
adultery and cheating is what are the
odds that a cheater actually stops if
they if you caught them you really think
that's the first time no not at all so
well cheating doesn't bother me that's
one thing yeah that's something that
there's something wrong with me it's not
normal i used to i used to i used to get
jealous but i think once i
when i went to vegas and i talked about
this in my earlier livestream today when
i went to vegas
you could say it's the epiphany phase
but like i was homeless dude like and i
felt so much better i felt safe because
i was i felt threatened at home with
my family member with mental illness and
stuff so when i found myself let's say i
was finally at peace
with being alone because i felt safe
i wasn't feeling safe for a long time
and i was surrounded by family friends
whatever so for me when it comes to
cheating
i just see it as another bump in the
road i don't know how those correlate
but there's something about it that i
don't get
maybe it's because i never had genuine
desire for somebody that's probably what
it was actually
i don't know
you've have you ever dated somebody that
you didn't get jealous
that you didn't go through their phone
um
well the first guy that i was that i
dated
i never went through his phone because i
was very naive so i never like
i never even like thought that should we
tell them i didn't i didn't think people
should tell them
you're your thing
she's a phone
she's a phone looker yeah i can i'll
i'll get my feelings hurt that's what if
i don't see it
i don't care i really don't give a [ __ ]
no i
because you can get an std like people
like i think it's so something i know
something funny yeah go ahead
guys are gonna think i'm i'm so sorry to
all my exes this is gonna make them look
a little
i know it doesn't look good every single
guy that i so i started dating every guy
that i had sex with
i never had sex with him before i would
demand an std test
before anything i don't give a [ __ ] is
this my camera i don't give a [ __ ] right
but if he's cheating on you
right so every six months that's what
you do you if i'm gonna get a checkup
so are you mm-hmm and you're paying for
it so i'm insurance
but yeah i don't care
that's the thing is like sure we can use
the argument that they're going to put
our health at risks most guys other than
athletes will use a condom on a side
pitch
trust me
what about an sti
oh here we go
sti is
name one what name one just so i'm like
clear oh gosh i have no idea okay hold
on no idea which one listen if it's
herpes you're asked i'm not that that's
what that that's for life you know okay
but it's treatable i've just heard
there's stis that condoms don't protect
you from
they probably protect for most
you know like but you're not wrong yeah
it's just like why would you if you love
someone why are you gonna you know but
it what if i told you it's not about
love so like for us
cheating see it's hard because i'm
[ __ ] up dude like i don't get jealous
but i have before so i can i can
empathize the thing with men cheating
is it's not
it's something like a
like a twitch
in them it's like uh what do we have
that's automatic what's something that
am i too low
it's kind of hard to hear me i don't
know my stuff was so loud in my ears
today
well it's different i agree that it's
different for men and women i'm not
saying it's right
but it's not something that i have found
evidence that you can
excuse me change like
women adapt
we pick up on so many things mm-hmm
social cues like men what did rolo say
like the girl at the club that gives us
a weird look we see that men don't at
all they don't see it at all i remember
when i heard that i was like really not
even a little bit like you can't tell
no they can't so when i think about
things that women
typically i know it's so complicated to
make it gender specific i don't want to
do that but it's like
there's not enough research to get all
157 genders like like a good amount
a good group
two tests you know but what i'm saying
is
i don't think men cheat because they
don't love us i think they get in
relationships no i i don't disagree with
you i but i do think it's selfish why
because who else are you thinking about
when you're having like okay like it's
literally pleasure for me
and i'm not thinking about anyone else
this could potentially break up my home
but i'm gonna do this but that's your
decision to break it up
most guys don't leave if they get caught
cheating
well that's what i'm saying it's like
i know it's like makes sense but like
why
but when women understand that cheating
isn't
when you can get to a place where
cheating isn't a deal breaker
because you don't know about it i'm not
saying that if you didn't find out you
wouldn't be pissed
you have every right to be but when you
realize why they do it it has nothing to
do if they love you i will say that it
probably has to do with you not giving
him something now if i'm not talking sex
there's something he's escaping from
maybe
but honestly
most men can't get women yeah i'm
putting it out there most of y'all can't
it's like the 2080 rule yeah yeah the
2080 rule yeah like so for me it's
almost like
if you can do that
do it
good for you
beat the odds like honestly but again
we're talking about
there's a possibility that they'll do it
that doesn't mean that the every single
dude will do it
what does donovan say i can't say it oh
women or men men don't cheat they have
not that
that one's a little that won't come out
of my mouth love you donovan but the one
that's like men are only
um cheating as often as as many options
as they have what is it
oh it's um okay under to 250 000 the
cheating like in income the cheating
rates 25 so one and four
but over no 250 000 it's 50 no like i'm
just saying that so so that that's data
that indicates that the more like
options a man has the more likely he is
to cheat but there's a way he says it's
oh i don't know it's like men are only
capable of having sexism as of like
if they have options they'll do it but
if they don't have options they won't
cheat because
how would they mm-hmm unless it was like
well and some some guys have options but
they're just busy like
like they work 80 90 hours a week
the ones that are really high value
really high value they have other people
doing it for them so if they're
but i speak from experience
if they're late at work or they're out
of town they're cheating for sure
who when you speak from experience did
you date a guy like that
dated three
oh well yeah
did they all cheat on you yeah
pretty sure i think i've been cheated on
by every single relationship but
remember i wasn't sexual
we talked about this earlier i wasn't a
sexual person i wasn't affectionate i'm
very i'm very aware of what i did not
give i wouldn't want to date me i was of
dude i was not i wasn't who i was i had
social anxiety like
so bad i couldn't go into a gas station
dude so imagine a guy who gets home from
work and then it's like i need him to
help me like i was helpless dude
i was annoying like i wasn't i've never
been a yeller i've never been a fighter
i've always been very rational calm and
thought you couldn't hurt my feelings if
you tried
maybe i'm a sociopath i don't know how
to be honest with you but
no i'm not
i cry
but like you know what i'm saying but
anyways okay so in the manosphere we're
switching topics because
men don't want to really hear about this
yeah okay in the mantesville
manosphere i love how you say man no
sphere
who i'm we're gonna play
who would you kill f
and mary okay all right
hold on
you got also guys uh moderators if i i
don't know really who's in the chat
right now you know this is a freedom of
speech thing
however
you're never allowed to talk smack about
my guests i didn't see anything i'm not
just like i'm just saying i forgot to
say this anything that uh
is showing up that you need to show it
just do it because i'm not looking at it
just be careful nothing sexual related
spam
they make us look bad so bad when they
do like the buy my crystals
you've seen that in the chat i'm like
thank you okay so we're going to play
kill mary
f okay
rolo to masi
myron gaines
and
does tim pool count i'm going to use tim
i mean
i wanted to give somebody that people
would hate
and i know
you don't
you don't have anything against anybody
like actually but you know
god
like this video if you haven't liked it
has to be those three yeah okay honestly
it's a game you have to put somebody in
a category
i
would probably
five four okay i would
i would marry
um
rolo probably he's got a wife okay okay
well these are my
i would probably
myron and kiltenpool just because i
don't
i'm so not going to age well but i love
it
okay you can play you can do it
backwards okay um you do
hi dad
um
okay
um
do
rolo
okay um
uh fresh okay and
donovan
this is like really uncool
okay
no offense donovan but i would kill you
if we were married so
i'm kidding
that
probably
um
[ __ ] rolo that sounds weird
afrolo
mary
fresh
um
see i would say mary rollo
he's very tolerable i don't know
but like he has a wife actually i would
marry
in this situation they're single like
you don't have to think about it oh then
i'd marry rolo for sure
yeah cause i get everything i'm kidding
uh and then kill
i'm killing donovan
and then
what's the other one f or yeah f i guess
i'm fn fresh
right
we both got starters it's okay
all right so now hold on
who said stop the cap that was as honest
as if
okay
hold on
is i can't see it i'm blind
are you putting them up on the screen
over there i won't be able to read it
lord i'm getting him so blind now
okay who else okay tla
the lead attorney
uh
you know we gotta have diversity i'm
trying to think of a white one it's not
coming to my mind i'm kidding uh
if it's mana sphere it's okay oh uh
anthony dream johnson
who's that
anthony
i'm the president of the manosphere
anthony
21 studios let me let me look hold on 21
studios
i don't i don't know if i know
i might sometimes i know people's faces
i know i feel you this guy
no
okay
he looks like a woke boy 21 studios
anthony is this middle this is not going
to age well it's okay anthony dream
that's him you know him come on
uh not really
yeah you do i don't think i've ever he's
doxed everybody in the sphere okay yeah
i don't know who that is but i'll i'll
do it like i'll put we'll i'll put him
in the three you know yeah yeah okay uh
so who else did i say tla okay him or
jack murphy
jack murphy
um he was just on you are here
jack murphy
this guy yeah
um okay that's oh this one's like my
eggs this one's easy um
if you knew the back story on
adj i think you would think otherwise
i don't pick it
no oh my gosh no the lead attorney i
would marry
okay um
he's so cute actually yeah and then
this guy
i would probably have and then
this guy i would kill because okay you
gotta be specific anthony dream john i'm
sorry anthony dream johnson
and jack murphy now you've you flipped
it you wanted to kill him no i wanted to
kill this guy no
but i don't i don't know though oh
god i just this the other guy was
younger like he's better looking
no
here i'll shut go that's is it not a
good picture it's bad once okay
um i just uh look up oh actually is that
him yeah
oh let me flip it yeah
yeah let me flip it
okay good
um okay wait for you yeah kevin samuels
okay
um
the lead attorney okay
and
myron okay
i know myron is into like sister wives i
don't think i could do that
um
you know what i think i'd marry
this is a horrible
lineup
tla
can i just like pick tla for all of them
i'm kidding
you know what i would
you know what i would marry myron
i would marry myron i'd feel sister
wives yeah okay
because i wouldn't have to deal with him
i'm kidding
no because i would feel safe
with his past work experience and that's
something that i really need if i'm
gonna marry somebody i have to feel safe
in a household
uh
i don't know about kevin samuels or tla
they just don't give me that vibe
not in a bad way
kevin samuels i don't want to kill
either
i guess i would kill tla
he he tries to run both sides of an
argument not in a bad way like
contradicts himself so you know what i
don't like that i'm kidding
um and i guess what's up what that i
would f kevin samuels is that what would
you do you'd kill him that's what he
could
if you kill the lead attorney nobody
will know wait so you're picking this
based on argue like their arguments no
i'm just picking whatever okay okay well
no i've met myron mm-hmm i would feel
safe with him i didn't speak to him that
much but he let me in his home so i'm
like fine
i don't want to kill anyone every human
life matters
attorney based on like that he plays
both sides i couldn't come up with
anything okay okay yeah i don't want to
kill anybody
if you do kill you have to have a reason
no
girl that's a volcano
like
in this hypothetical
that's not fair this game is rigged this
is my show
okay tla is an attorney so of course he
has to analyze those sides
no comment
uh what's this um rue is this somebody
um
i'm ro
who's that a-m-r-o-u
is that a name that you know i'm sorry
a notorious creep with women you know
these like let me see that's the name a
is m the fitness guy i don't know do you
know who he is tony
can we pull up a quick google thing on
the camera
put it on my phone my phone's gonna die
um you too luckily
she does
i keep forgetting i got two
phones we should this guy i've never
seen him
wait we can put it towards the camera
he looks like he would murder me first
wait who is that
i don't know my piece oh my god
everybody's
check my text
guys you know
hey
so
all right
okay see
[ __ ] mary kell
um are you gonna show the camera
yeah i'll show you uh wait he said the
names
uh [ __ ] mary kill the save oh brothers
rocky me mark from left to right okay
okay i gotta show the camera
should i show this one
hi
my phone's i tried to clean it with a
makeup wipe it's not looking good
okay let me
everybody knows who they are i don't
yeah i've never seen them um
that mommy's in the club so i don't know
what any of them talk like so i can't
base this on anything but this picture
but i think it would be mary
f
kill like just based on their faces if
you ever say that you will f by mans
i will be very upset
okay so she said from left to right
right yeah and then it was
yeah mary f k it's just based on like i
think he's the most attractive second
third
okay
okay i like that
truth or dare
truth or dare um
dare
do you have anything on underneath no
oh no i'm kidding
i'm like do you have anything on under
that
okay i dare you
to call myron right now
you have to i dared you you have his
number i don't and you're gonna
you're gonna say
hey you dropped something your standards
hi i'm pearl
no yeah you have to it's a do you have
to yeah come on it's fun
oh my god that awkward moment when
oh
you have to
don't [ __ ] out now
but if he doesn't answer then can i
like that i'm cool right
for the meantime somebody will get a
hold of him
someone will get somebody will i'm sure
no way roloff you're watching this
just do it
he won't answer
that's what people are saying you think
what if he knows already
facetime no no one answers facetime
that's a chicago thing for sure
i forgot five four
three
i don't want to do it
okay if you don't want to that's okay
no i told you you couldn't decline okay
i i can't even make her take a shot
that's not right okay um
how about how about
i don't want to do that that's so
awkward um okay whoever loses has to
promote each other non-stop for one week
okay like annoyingly i don't mind losing
this will be fun oh so i'm gonna do them
back to you now so since i chickened out
so it's like okay i get you um truth or
dare
dare
um my phone's gonna die so i'll have to
use yours if you want me to follow
someone
um okay
i dare you
i'm scared but i'm not scared
like this video if you haven't liked it
yet
i could use my phone if you like need me
to but i just i feel like everything has
to be your phone
i know for the viewers yeah yeah cause
like you don't want to make me get naked
you don't want to do it right i get it
my thoughts exactly
i dare you to post on your story
that
that you've had diarrhea for a week
strain
and if i ask if anyone has any tips
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'm such a kid
gonna know i'm [ __ ] kidding you could
have done so much better
i'll do a lot of [ __ ] final answer yeah
okay
i'm gonna put a filter on though
[Laughter]
guys i've had diarrhea oh
no no it's gotta be a video they're not
a video i'm saying like put it as a
as a like a text
so not cool
that's not even fun
what do you mean i think i need
personalities no i'll say it serious
should i go sit on the toilet
yeah you can do it on the toilet
oh my god i do not like that i chickened
out i like
oh my god i do not like that i chickened
out
um
i wanna see what
is this a fresh
i guess i gotta put good truth or dares
in the chat what nothing
what'd you do
no i said put good truth or dares in the
chat okay
ready okay
truth or dare
truth
careful
i'm very mean with truth okay
very mean
no i'm kidding i'm not uh
what would you rate yourself one through
time looks go
um
get closer to the mic five
why five
um because
i feel like i'm average looking
okay
i gotta i don't i've never like because
i feel like eight to ten as a model i
feel like six is cute i feel like when i
have makeup on i'm cute
but i feel like when like just
like not dressed up five
okay and like when i'm dressed up six
maybe seven on like a good day i lost 10
pounds let me see what
are you checking my story no i thought
you i was checking the chat what'd you
do in the chat no nothing no did you do
something no no i just asked people to
put in truth or dares let me see
what'd they say
no nothing yeah nothing is it going come
on guys okay
um i don't know i i think like a normal
i feel like the manosphere scale is
different from the rest of the world the
way they would i think you scaled it
like the manosphere yeah
i did but but it's such a hard one
because then they would say do you have
low self-esteem or something it's like
i'm like a very insecure person
yeah no
see i think i'm very uncomfortable
like
[Laughter]
like the answer would be yes
like absolutely
i'm sorry i don't know why i think it's
so funny like yes
do you have abandonment issues obviously
test me my track how do you not have a
phone charger here you don't have one
okay okay no i i do but i'm worried that
i'm not
actually worried about anything yeah can
i get a charger in this [ __ ] actually i
have i was like you have to have one
somewhere now
really
i don't know all my we're not my typical
room
okay truth or dare
truth
okay um i don't have one ready i have to
think okay hey what's your dare i knew
you had one ready to go no i didn't
either okay
neither okay do you wanna stick to truth
i don't care
let me see if the chat gave me any
um
okay i don't think they did i'm not oh
uh
if you could go on a date
with one part like um
with one person in the manosphere
assuming
no wives or anything assuming they're
single who would you go on a date with
and like date seriously like is there
anyone you have a crush on everybody
knows hold on
hold on
i'm so weird okay
who's that
don't say it yet
he's probably smiling he loves it
everybody all know
i was listening right when you called me
you want to go out with me i'm just
kidding
yeah when you want to get together i
thought you were going to come out here
and see me
and see you but i'll tell you what this
is definitely
not as good as calling pression fit on
the air
i know but you know what when you were
saying that though i was thinking
they're on right now so that was going
to be a dub
do you think so
i don't know fresh no okay well if
anybody's cut the hook up
yeah
okay bye
bye
what
that's it
you're very quiet like and you're
usually very loud
i wanted her to hear your voice oh damn
i should have called him cause he
probably wouldn't have answered yeah
you're down here
it's quiet in my headphones i think
can you blast it in my ears tony
i forgot that i have headphones on right
now you probably sound fine but yeah
that's good tony
um
they're red i'm nervous
anyways that's it that's all you got to
say
do you love me savo
oh thank you tony
he won't say
most of us are men we don't teach are
you just going to ignore me while we're
live
it's too short
yeah that's a good excuse
yeah i can put it in through here
no i can't um
yeah i'm like how do you not know who
she is
yeah do you think he sounds good speak
closer to the phone
so annoying
hold on
five
four
three two
hi is that better yeah now that's way
better
introduce yourself i put thought mommies
on non-stop on her live stream
non-stop i'm kevin i'm kevin sabo i'm
somewhat known in the sphere
a red pill rapper keep talking uh yeah
that's kind of how it the way it's
worked out because we did a song about
eight [ __ ] single mothers and it kind of
became a thing in the sphere and rolo
tamasi got behind it oh
[Music]
[Music]
is it like rap music it was the thought
mommies oh that was you
oh i love that song is it
see
he's kind of the [ __ ] he writes he's a
poet
he writes he has a book out where's he
thought crime i always say thought where
are you at
i'm not in connecticut oh connecticut
milford
uh what else does he do he
save a whole did you see rolo's cameo
when he was like
you totally did it was on fresh and fit
how'd you miss it really i don't watch
freshman foot no but you saw it it was a
thing it was rolo's acting it was good
it was if it was a clip maybe yeah
that's his
i don't know i didn't i don't know just
say it's good okay
yeah okay we're getting married
for sure
what did you say you heard me
fast
what
what'd you say
i said tori likes to brush things a
little bit shut the [ __ ] up you know
exactly what you say off camera
i'll leave it at that goodbye
[ __ ]
done okay
okay is that it
that was my dare yeah or truth
truth yeah okay truth or dare
truth
okay
i'm being respectful of your exes
i've tried so hard
truth really come on okay dare i dare
you
i'm
kidding
i dare you too
guys is donovan on right now
i don't have his number
do you have this number yeah okay what
i
wait
donovan was hilarious and save ohio
people are like rolo rollo guys
won't okay what do you what do you want
me to do
dare wise yeah
i dare you
who was your last employer
um
okay
konica minolta
what the company what company hanukkah
minolta do you have your boss's number
no my boss got fired from that company
perfect call that boss
and you're gonna confess your feelings
and how you really want to have a one
night stand you've never had one
you're horny
oh my god you are brutal i'm telling you
i'm a sociopath
but it's fun is he what is he ugly he's
a girl
[ __ ] it okay no i want you to call a man
i want to see what he says okay we need
a man okay um what about your no you
can't do your couch is it a girl or a
guy like coach oh i don't even have wait
do you have any girls on your team that
are gay
um
i don't think so not that i know it's
like such a stereotype i hate it no i'm
not on the volleyball team basketball
team basketball and softball yeah when i
was on the basketball team
in the u.s like i could have yeah
okay the guy that you were recently
talking to
is that okay if i say okay
i dare you
to break up with him on camera
[Music]
no i can't do that okay that's fine
oh my god that's fine
i'm losing this chicken game you sure
did
okay
um
okay this is my last one right
that was your last one okay um truth or
dare have i lost yet no so don't i win
by default i mean i'll do it okay um
truth
do dare
lie
okay
um
okay
hold on let me let me think this through
you can sit with it while she sits with
it guys like this video leave a comment
four words for the algorithm
share this to twitter
tag my ass it's good for my seo
call your dad
and tell him
that
you're careful
i can't give this man a heart attack
like seriously he's old like
what is it
that
um you've decided to go into porn
no
he'll literally have a heart attack dude
he's like almost 80.
okay
chicken right i guess
a chicken [ __ ] you
my dad would be like what
[Music]
fair so i won
so now you have to take my you have to
be obnoxious like i don't even want you
to do it number five it's like it's like
i promote you for a week yeah but that's
like annoying like non-stop i meant like
it's like
[Laughter]
oh my god
okay that was good
starting good truth or dare like you
were very creative i would not have been
yeah it's because i have no feelings but
i observe feelings but i i still try to
be
fun
i hope it was fun no it was i just was
like oh my god i had like three of those
give me a heart attack
oh yours gave me one like i could never
disrespect my father like
he has too much going on at home
we need him alive
she says okay
uh
what the [ __ ] is going on
that's harsh what's harsh
was mine harsh or was yours probably
mine
yeah
oh this way i have to crack my neck
ow
okay whatever have you ever
effed with a volleyball player
no we didn't have a men's team at my
school
what school again
i went to elmhurst oh yeah so we didn't
have a men's team
did you ever
do you know any girls on the team that
messed with the coach just to be on the
team is that a thing
not at a d3 school um
but
there was there was um a coach a
basketball coach that actually hooked up
with a girl after she graduated
so it was illegal
yeah like it was
but yeah that that's not uncommon i had
a coach in high school
that weighed it yeah he
oh my gosh it's just so traumatizing
because i i was so close with him like i
was so close with him like i did
one-on-one training with him a couple
times a week did he hug you and that
makes me wait wait so he he was um
an ex-nfl player
um robert is his name robert
that sounds close to his last name
was he black yeah
oh my god 1981
oh my god dude i'm done don't even say
it on camera
how do you know him because he used to
come into twin peaks
oh my god no he he like waited until a
girls would turn i mean i'm just so
creepy yeah i was i used to look at i
remember looking at him like a dad like
for a while because i saw him so much
yeah and then the first time i went back
from college to go because it's normal
to go see your old coaches if you're an
athlete yeah and so i went to see him
and like he
yeah he he
he won the super bowl in either 81 or
83. i don't know um i don't know i
didn't hear about football was it bears
it was the bears yeah guys
yeah i got him fired from my high school
i'm like 100 dead i was no i was not
playing because wait so what happened i
was like so so he he i was um
this was a while ago now because i think
i was 18 or 19 when this happened so i
was the first time i went back from
college okay and it was the first time
i'd seen him since i was 18 pretty much
okay so he i said oh can i come to the
gym and he was like oh let's go get
lunch and then when we went into it's
like not that weird i didn't like i
didn't think so you have to understand i
didn't do [ __ ] in high school so i was i
was very you know i would have no idea
that it got weird yet yeah so then it
started to get weird at lunch where he
would just say
i don't know like you look beautiful
like oh like he would make comments on
my leggings i remember that was like the
first i was like okay but i'm very much
i give people the benefit of the doubt
so i was like oh whatever you know
you're just used to it yeah
and then he um
i forgot and then he started asking me
about like boys i'm at college
i was like oh you know whatever but then
so then i where did you guys get
you know who owns
dude if you knew the people that run it
were uh
like um
bartenders at twin peaks the managers
dude
i i don't know i i all i know was one
indication that i think he was an
alcoholic in hindsight oh absolutely in
hindsight but when i went there everyone
knew him i was like oh he's so cool like
whatever no he's there every day yeah
but then so then um i left and he calls
me on my way back and he's like oh come
take a shot at the gym with me like a
chat and at first i was like oh no i'm
not trying to drink tonight because it
was like my finals week that's why i was
home but he kept like going at it and i
was like you know what it'd be funny to
tell like my friends because i remember
thinking it'd be funny to tell my
friends i took a shot with my ex coach
because i was like 18 or 19. so i go to
the gym
and he like gives me a drink or whatever
and there's no one there but like dumb
ass me didn't know alarm bells because i
was very sheltered you were yeah you do
and and so be careful if you
plan to do this as a dude because we
tell friends yeah so then we go on
trying to think so we're sitting i'm
sitting with like there's two couches
there and i'm sitting like across from
him i'm already uncomfortable and yeah
guys this man is in his 60s 50s or 60s i
think at the time because i remember one
of the conversations we had was i was
like you're old
and he was trying to convince me he's
not no he's he has a daughter two years
younger than me like literally and so i
i went so i'm sitting there and uh the
weird okay this is gonna be pause first
yeah guys just so you know i've always
dated guys that were at least four years
older like that seems to be the thing so
i've been i've dated guys that have been
a decade older than me like
a decade older
one but whatever so i have nothing
against that
however i've been really into
reading about like uh do you remember
that one guy courtney stodden and dave
hutchinson or whatever so when you're
telling me this that's what i have in my
mind keep going i don't know who they
are the girl that got married when she
was 16 and he was 50 i used to not think
that was weird as a kid i think he was
in his late 30s like i think he was 39
because i remember having a conversation
never mind different saying that
actually i could look up his age right
now
um yeah i think we're talking about the
same person i think so too because pub47
the girls that bartended there
yeah
that's who we're talking about right
can you
no look up uh super bowl when did the
bears win the super bowl in the 80s
i know that he was like
he's on there i'll know him when i see
him
[Music]
um he would sit by himself and drink for
like hours dude
which is sad and you guys know my thing
about addiction i don't know what you'd
google
super bowl
close bears if it's
okay
yeah it's 1985 okay
so then
1985.
i feel like he he was a big dude i feel
like he was what the block is that
somebody
like what are you what's this position
they're looking white
that's not true
oh that's cute like what the hell
um
why don't i just look up his like wick
wikipedia hold on oh you had
rob wait don't don't say this yeah um
yeah
i feel like i like when i let's see
he
no i don't think we're talking i don't
think we're talking about the same
person i don't think so either this guy
was like
sorry yeah because i think cause i
remember it was he was in his late 30s
because i said oh you're like my dad's
age you're old
he was trying to but i was 18. that's
not old nate you you think 39
that's kind of old like for an 18 year
old i mean i have i have like trauma
like i'm like old you know like but at
the same time i don't know his daughter
was like two years younger than me i
thought it was weird but
the are you surprised are you surprised
or do you think it's strange like let's
clarify i'm i was very surprised at the
time because what happened was we were
sitting like i was sitting across from
him why you're like a virgin what you
were like a virgin i was that's what i'm
saying like why would he you know yeah
it's [ __ ] up
no and so i
so he was across from me and he said i i
said i wanted to go to a club downtown
okay and he was like oh if you go to
this club like you'll have to give the
bouncer up
and i was like what the [ __ ]
no you flash your tits maybe but like
well
you went i don't know why that was the
first where i was like okay well
i don't want to go to this i want to
know what he's doing right no guys if
you didn't catch that i don't know she
motioned uh
on job you know he's testing the waters
testing it's kind of like when your ex
comes back into your life and like how
are you doing he's like testing to see
how you'd react
and so then he goes he says
like the gym i don't want to go to the
club well yeah yeah i was like okay we
can find a different bar
we can find a different place to go
we can't
go anywhere else
but
but he so he goes what did he say he
said
you um then sonny goes you know like
hannah because my first time stand up
the gym the gym's empty right now we
could do anything you want i'm like what
do you mean marcus
and i'm like what what do you mean and
order pizza and then
he's like i think you know it i mean and
like
yeah and then i was like and then so
then i said
i do i
do i um i was like i think i do know
what you mean
but i'm gonna like pretend like i don't
and then i laugh that was it and you
didn't try to persuade him now then you
know he that's this is how i got him
fired because after i left he texted me
he texted me so he said um he said come
back to the gym tonight and i said for
what and then he said like
um nothing just sex
and then and so then i was like guys but
i actually didn't i didn't get him fired
until years later because my mom told me
not to she i don't know why she did this
but my mom literally i wanted to tell
his wife what's your mom's name um jen
jen okay keep going um
because well no i think she had a
conversation with the guy that
my club guys i see you in the chat she's
19.
okay
she's still in school or she came back
to visit him
guys
stop it
what are they saying it's it's because i
was over 18 right
yeah dude it's like okay on well no the
issue i had was he was waiting until
girls turned 18 to try to hook up with
him i found other stories too
so you're you're literally grooming yeah
you're gross
like you forget what groominess i think
enough like i was training with him
since i was 14. and like as soon as this
happened i remembered all these
conversations that in hindsight were so
inappropriate yeah that he had with me
and so what i did was i wrote like a
letter and like i documented everything
i remembered everything that just
happened and then did you get paid
no oh no you don't understand why that
was wait wait wait do you know do you
know why i got him fired
because he he coached at my club and
that
happened behind the scenes wait so the
club is like uh like like a volleyball
club okay so he was a trainer at a
volleyball club but this is like where
you're it's like uh so okay i should i
should preface so i the volleyball club
murals or no no this is competitive
what's that called very it's um like
traveling yeah travel it was travel
volleyball got it so he was the trainer
the head trainer he trained all the
girls on top of that he did one-on-one
training that was what i did with him in
the summers yeah gave me like the that's
where i got to know him you're giving me
nassar vibes yeah like if you know you
know so so then that's how i got to know
him like because it was the one-on-one
sessions over the summer that's why i
said i was very close with him i looked
at him as like a father figure
and so then on top of that a couple
years later i find out he is going to be
a coach at my high school my old high
school on the track team my sister's
going to run track oh stop yeah and so i
i i was like oh hell no i do not care
who i have to talk to
and so wait so you lost me okay yeah
hold on go back okay
what else made you uncomfortable when
you had one-on-one coaching
wait you're saying like okay so in
hindsight in hindsight
okay
25 year old when he he told me
before i went to college like that i was
going to get a bunch of attention from
boys because of my butt
let me see it i didn't look
because at the time and you know you
just kind of brushed it off you know
what i mean because you're okay you said
that at 17 yeah and there was other [ __ ]
too that like later i looked back
because this was so long ago now that
it's you know foggy yeah but like i
remember writing down like stuff he said
to me and i like went to the school
like while i was under age and so i'm
thinking because i remember saying like
you can tell me stuff you don't like you
don't tell your parents yeah like who's
well you're the oh he said he said that
who who says that to
like he's grooming yeah and so that's
like like it doesn't get more i'm good
a couple years later i find out that he
is going to coach my sister because
otherwise i was just going to let it go
whatever but because you thought it was
like just you like maybe you guys had
like a connection or whatever honestly
yeah i didn't i didn't think he was
doing it to multiple girls and that's
that's where we go wrong yeah like i
totally get that in your situation yeah
yeah so i find out that he um is going
to coach my sister and
i don't even get along with that sister
like i have one sister that growing up
we never got along but i swear to god i
was not about to let her know so i still
had the text so i had his number i had i
printed everything out that i had from
him
and then
um and even inappropriate like stuff
he'd kind of sent me before there's
stuff that doesn't like when you say it
doesn't even sound inappropriate it's
only you that are gonna experience it
and you remember it in hindsight you
don't have to like say it right because
like i always thought people were just
being nice i know and and it's it's hard
to explain because when you're 25 and
older like or 22 21 whatever your brain
sort of starts to like change a little
bit or you look back it does with
experience but at the time you don't and
so yeah i went to the principal and then
i got him fired and i don't know i'm
sure he's still doing like something
today with athletics but
yeah i like that's i'm so sorry i mean
i'm fine now i was sad at the time
because i like literally
like it's your fault too like forgetting
no
i thought it was just
i did not think it was much like the
pharmacist with me like i just don't
have the balls to get them like fired
fired dude like i and that's my problem
but i also went in there to pick up like
my
meds when i had to go to downtown and i
was running late like i was in that's
like not saying that a victim's asking
for it i know what i mean but i was
being very friendly it was well and then
i after i find out that he he did this
to a girl that actually ended up
committing suicide he would like hook up
with her and like pay her rent all the
time and she ended up committing suicide
i don't know if it was it probably
wasn't just about him like you know what
guys i'm gonna say this
i know that guys are attracted to the 22
year old age and that's fine but i'm
telling you something goes on between 18
without a host stage okay let's make
that clear something goes on between the
ages i'll say this
15
16 a lot and then 16 to 17 it's like eh
and then but 16 to 18
a lot but you're still even
one day after your freaking birthday
even up until 21 i would say 21 it's
like okay it can kind of settle but
you're still not aware of your own
behaviors like you are at 23. but when
men have the capacity to [ __ ] up women
sexually and i will say that
so stop it like seriously
no i know i've had mannose for people
like like com like i can tell they're
from the man of spirit comment because
i've told this story on like a tick tock
before
and it's weird they blame you like they
put the you the 17 18 year old
yeah i guess like why did you put
yourself in that situation or you liked
the attention
yeah you do like the attention at that
age because you have to remember like
most people at school are bullying you
even if you're the nicest person you
know what i mean it's like well and i
liked that because my dad was gone a lot
he worked a lot so i liked the attention
from having like like an older male
figure to be honest
i thought i was cool i could buy the
liquor for kids and you know what i i'm
happy that the person i was involved
with was a good man like honestly
because i
could have been a lot
could have been a lot worse but you know
what i'm saying like they have the
capacity to do that i would have changed
anything about what i looked like i
would have gotten anything done and that
you look at kylie jenner and tyga
why the hell was that not on the news he
was grooming her at 13 dude and people
you know what it's not necessarily the
ages but i was trying to explain it's
like the the life experiences
and i'm telling you i used to think it
was [ __ ] when people say i'm like
i'm 16. i could date a 22 year old
there's not that much different
it's like uh no a lot of girls i would
say
think that they're going for the high
value man because they're a couple what
my god no i never age was never a thing
for me i never was attracted to like old
guys it wasn't that i was attracted
remember i don't get that like inkling
it was that and i've i told you this off
camera that they provided something for
me that and you guys know this so don't
act all surprised like the home guy
[ __ ]
[ __ ] face
like he offered me a pl like his home so
and i thought i was gonna get killed at
mine so like for me that was the like
when you think about women finding men
back in the day because they want to
make sure that they don't die when they
give child birth it was the same idea
just like living it's it's interesting
because when i i never looked at guys as
like a means for money it wasn't like
that though it was like an escape it was
like it was like a home like he cared to
get me out of there because i genuinely
thought i was gonna like not but you
know
we are not going to talk about that but
you know what i'm saying like and he
you know i didn't have a car and he
would let me drive his truck and so like
i had a means to escape and so that's
what drew me to him
on on the
he was emotionally unavailable you
[ __ ] my friend like there's just so
much i just couldn't i was young i was
younger but i don't know guys i'm just
saying like you can go for young girls i
hope you do just be careful and be
conscientious of what you're doing you
guys have a tendency to be manipulative
okay um there's ethical game and i think
it's gonna become a really big thing
but you don't and i know that it's so
easy to tell a girl
exactly what she wants to hear and what
i mean by that is if she says she wants
a relationship and you know damn well
that you wouldn't marry this [ __ ]
stop it
you [ __ ] him up when you act like you
will
be there or you want that do you see i
see a lot of girls
like the guy tells them that they just
don't listen actually more than i watch
their actions yeah
because they move a certain way trust me
if it doesn't line up you know um
you don't know i used to question it all
the time like is this one of those
and i've been fortunate to date really
great men so and there was like two that
i
you know maybe talk smack about but they
were still and i know everybody laughs
when girls say he's like a guy though
this guy was
there's more to the story guys i just
can't say it on the internet okay but
what was i going where was i going with
that i don't know [ __ ] it was uh
uh he was a good dude but
he was like tony do you remember that
was important i lost it
oh they tell so if i used to question
like okay how do i know if they're being
authentic or not i've been fortunate
that i've dated a lot of good men but
those two men showed me very well what
they do when they don't want to be with
you long term people are like why didn't
you settle with a high value guy guys he
didn't want to marry me
you out of your mind
like
no
no and you want to know how i knew that
i'm thinking how did i know that i knew
it
because he made me
you know what i'm not gonna say it on
the internet i'll tell you off camera
but it was
what
feminism would think is controlling
behavior
just use your imagination they would
think it's controlling behavior
and then [ __ ] you over so hard so what's
controlling behavior clothes like uh no
it's not that
but if let's say you try to get somebody
hypothetically i'm gonna say
hypothetically
you tell them to quit all their jobs
and then
all that stuff comes out as revenge to
try to hurt my feelings and stuff
[ __ ] you
dude like [ __ ] you that's somebody that
said all the right things in the
beginning you know he took me he tried
like he opened my eyes to so many
awesome places he told me everything i
wanted to hear
and then
[ __ ] played me dude but genuine guys
they'll be consistent they'll call you
every day they'll
they'll set the times
they'll if it doesn't work
it like we can have an honest
conversation like i don't think it's
working out and respect each other and
leave like it's nothing spiteful
it's never let me call you back i've
never had a guy and that's probably to a
fault but
guys have respected me so well that i
know it's like
you don't have to respect that woman
they've respected me so well that when i
said do do not contact me after
they never did like very good men
so i don't know that's me
i feel like i talked a lot that's not
about me let's see the chat
what about you what what do you mean
when you think you're saying
a lot of men
say the right things but they don't move
in the right way no i said a lot of guys
will tell girls they're not looking for
something serious or a relationship and
girls don't believe them
and they just keep like they're attached
or whatever but why do you think they're
attached
why what are they doing because a lot of
times well they're they're hooking up
with them they're sleeping with them so
i think a lot of times guys will say oh
i don't want a relationship right now
key word it's always right now they give
you the whole the girl will say i don't
want a relationship too but she doesn't
mean it she doesn't i've said this yeah
she doesn't mean it she doesn't guys she
you know what all the male dating
coaches are telling women to be carefree
don't put a timeline on it it may just
seem like you're you'd give it up but
not too quickly and it's like
you do realize you're gonna get yourself
in a whole lot of trouble doing that
you're gonna end up sleeping with them
very early he's not gonna
you guys act like you want somebody with
genuine desire but we need to be
specific you want somebody that will
hold out but still show interest
we usually go radio silent as donovan
will put it like we do
but
i don't know i think
i pay attention to actions dude
like
you really think women don't believe
them no i think they're getting
manipulated
no i think i think girls i i don't know
dude i've seen a lot i've never had a
guy tell me that so you have to you have
to be specific even if it's anecdotal
with a friend whatever give me an
example
i'm yelling there was
there was a girl on my volleyball team
that would just continue to hook up with
this guy that like was never gonna date
her and she knew that
he wasn't gonna date her why is she
doing that
is she she's having fun let's see she
like like she you know that's like with
the alpha
and she cheated on her next boyfriend
with the old guy even though this man
bought her a house
wait this man literally bought her a
house and she still cheated on him with
the guy that would never date her you do
realize why
the alpha beta yeah okay just making
sure okay um
but ann that guy tried to oh my god i
remember i asked him once because he
would cheat
on his girlfriend with the girl on my
team and like one time because he was
it's like a small school yeah and one
time i was like in the back seat of a
car with him and like there's other
people in the front but they went in to
go get like liquor and i just i was done
drinking so i just stayed with him yeah
and he tried to kiss me and i was like
what like stop and he he and he and i
literally asked him i'm so mad because
they they came in i don't know the
number but they came back in the two
people came back and so i never got the
answer to this question but i like
looked at him i'm like you have a hot
girlfriend at home it doesn't matter and
i was like why like why no [ __ ] is yeah
yeah
you can't compete [ __ ] you can't
i was like you have like this girl
sleeps with you that girl sleeps with
you she might not be sleeping with him
you know what i'm saying he might not be
getting laid but still i i don't know
give her the benefit i remember he just
he i just remember his eyes were so wide
because he was not expecting me to like
ask him a question or say no
and then and then they came back like he
was shocked yeah because i was genuinely
big i was very cheap
like why like why do you do this i don't
i don't understand
yeah like they genuinely see what he
looks like okay i don't i don't know if
i still because i don't follow that many
people um so i don't know she's too cool
no you follow me i think so okay i only
follow like 50 people
the show
um i only followed my
boyfriend when we were together like for
a while that's why
um
i don't know let me see if he's on
facebook
because i like i literally don't
remember his last name
i
said stop grabbing her you guys you know
i've only been waking up to this
stuff like
the grooming thing
recently
and it's just
i found him
like they're kids dude like just leave
them alone
so you're into chocolate
oh i know i didn't
he tried to kiss me i know but yeah i'm
just saying
um
i have two types um
he's good looking yeah he's good but
let me see the girl
i feel like okay correct me if i'm wrong
no i shouldn't say that right that's
funny which one his actual girlfriend or
the girl that would the one at the time
the girlfriend at the yeah the girl on
my team
oh right there because they never like
the he didn't date the girl on my team
yeah show me both okay
who was he banging and who was he dating
okay um i like
my it says my
the video resolution is not supported do
i not put it oh my god thank you for the
five dollar chat i didn't see that guys
i'm not remember his ex-girlfriend's
name
a super chat tony will you let me know
when there's super chats
i wasn't looking yeah oh it's riley
thanks for trying to remember his ex
girls
i can show you the girl in my team
okay um the she was the girlfriend was
probably like kind of similar look with
just a little
how's it going
yeah you're hotter
for sure
not not then the girlfriend oh no was
the girlfriend like uh
bougie what did we call it yeah she was
she was very pretty i would i would put
her at
seven or eight what's her body because
that's what guys care about um
was she fat nope no no okay no like yes
thinner than me better body than me i
would say no no tits like big butt
that's that's what i'm thinking yeah
okay um that's ideal but not not huge
like like big butt for being like a thin
girl yeah like not hey better than me
you know i have nothing so it's like
when i you know it's proportionate for
her right
so that girl looked and this was the one
you showed me is the one that was just
sleeping with him
i will tell you right now i bet you she
has low self-esteem
she's not ugly i'm not saying she's ugly
but there's something i i want to put a
name on these [ __ ] because they all
look the same to me
it's like um
they're the good girls see people say
that
every girl is a bad girl until she gets
caught right something like that but
there's some girls that
really play the goody two-shoe and
they're not like that's the crazy thing
she she really didn't sleep around she
really it was just for him it was
literally like like if i could if she
does if i could if i could know if i
could think of like alpha widow that's
what i think of that situation okay
so yeah i feel it
like
did she try to justify it like he's
gonna date me
no i didn't really ask because
like she's not what happened like one
time oh my gosh one time her boyfriend
oh god this was so bad her boyfriend
came to
[Music]
like a party late okay and like
literally probably 45 minutes before you
got there she hooked up with the guy
in the bathroom at the party he came to
[ __ ] hate [ __ ] i
[ __ ] i know but it's such a it's such
an awkward situation because
what are your options as the girl you
tell the boyfriend that you don't know
no and then no i know but like what does
that do for me then then i lose this
girl it's awkward for me
like i lose this girl you're saying what
is the the dude what am i supposed to do
with that for you yeah like nothing i
know that's what you do
nothing yeah you don't do [ __ ] you
[ __ ] observe you're like okay these
people are nuts and then like that's it
yeah and and then talk about it on my
pocket because she she was normal like i
it was just like if i if i think of
alpha widow this is what i think of can
you define alpha whatever alpha widow's
like i know i guys you know i [ __ ]
this one up it's basically the girl
she's a guy's the best she's ever gonna
get and so even when she has like new
boyfriends she still compares him i feel
like to the old boyfriend and like
basically like they would drop
the new boyfriends with like the drop of
a hat never go back to any my exes ever
there's none that sticks out to me like
oh my god
like we talk about the guy with the home
because everybody's like oh my gosh a
millionaire blah blah blah no
no he's [ __ ] traumatizing dude like
no thank you
um me
never mind uh i don't want to talk about
him i feel like he just
no there's no one i compare to
what about you
compare i was for a long time i was
obsessed the guy a lot like the guy lost
my virginity too i was like obsessed
with really yeah i like oh my god yeah
me too but not like that i forgot about
him
he ran over my foot on accident that's
how we met
no i
yeah that was like the biggest waste of
time in my life well that's why you
gotta take the risk right
sucks
no oh
yeah i wish i didn't take that risk we
all do it's time you can't get back
i would
what would it have gone differently
no
like was there anything you could do to
fix it genuinely
that you wouldn't have learned if you
weren't dumped
um
oh my neck hurts so bad how are you
doing tony okay well he um
no there's a lot of [ __ ] i wish it's
interesting though the in the
manosphere's perspective like the girl
because what happened was um two weeks
after like we ended it he starts dating
a new girl
i was you know um and he ends up like
he's he's i think did he have a snapchat
he did didn't he enough said guys if you
are a dude let me give you some advice
okay it doesn't matter if you're not on
social media but you have a snapchat
nothing says i have stds like i have a
snapchat i'm done
actually at the time everyone had one it
doesn't matter everyone has dude if a
guy has a high snap score no i don't
think he did i'm telling you everyone
did a guy that has a snapchat is looking
for attention the same way a woman is
posted
i disagree
i disagree because at the time at the
time it was really common like you would
group cats with okay okay okay you you
did they post like what'd they post what
was like their story tell me no he never
had a story exactly it's like outside
what i'm saying like like i'm telling
you at the time this was when i was i'm
25 now so i was 19. same thing at the
time i'm a year older okay okay like
when i was in college it was super
normal everyone talked on snapchat yeah
i wonder why i
freaking thought i'm kidding
no it was like we talked to my teammate
i don't know but right now like if
you're in like a group but
to be fair like he he probably he
probably was obviously but but it's
funny because
because they um
know
what track you on there too but keep
going off topic um but he i'm trying to
think so yeah he ends up like
like i think he's gonna marry that girl
or dad i don't really know but
yeah i was like obsessed i was so sad
because i i felt like i waited cause i
was almost i was a sophomore in college
when i lost my virginity so i was like
halfway through college it was late for
most girls so this is his second
girlfriend that he married wait no no no
he was older than me oh okay so he he
did girlfriends before me but
you know it's not about you it's i'm
gonna drop something it's the timing
well no no i it actually it was because
he literally like went on to marry the
next girl so something but it's funny
because the girl the girl was older than
me so by the manosphere's perspective
like i would have won you know what i
mean like i like on paper like
i'm pretty realistic with myself i think
i was prettier than her yeah i like
what's your worst trait my worst trait
um talk too much
dude i feel like that too yeah like i
said like high energy yeah high energy
but guys like um
fun yeah so when you say that do you
mean you forget to ask about them
i do
[Music]
like no hate like i i ask a lot of
questions i get asked i get told i ask
too many questions
oh yeah like you get personal quickly
can you hear me but i think i think i
forget important details about people
that is like important for them that i
know i know isn't that the worst but i i
just genuinely i forget i forgot
birthdays i forget you want to know why
why because you don't care
i know i know that's how i can tell that
i actually am a little maybe
not genuine desire but that i i like
them
no but this guy i was obsessed with you
would remember his favorite color
no i was obsessed with him i'm telling
you what kind of details because maybe
it was
um what kind of details like maybe he
was telling the other [ __ ] and told
thought he told you too and would get
mad at you listen guys oh no no no
no no no no not not that one i was
thinking my like last sorry friend i'm
like very confused with timelines
because
my last boyfriend would just
get mad if i didn't like he would he
would just if i forgot certain things
not mad but just like annoyed with bee
at least he would would show something
like so you were aware of it a lot of
guys don't tell you and then like you're
dumped and you're like what would i do
like i'd rather y'all tell me so i can
do better
you know but
do you miss him
do i miss him now oh no yeah
no um
well i mean my last like boyfriend i do
because yeah i'm talking about like the
one from college oh no like no i mean
the last last one like recently oh the
recent oh yeah i switched around
we broke up like
like not long ago at all so yeah guys
what's an appropriate time for her to
start dating again like just in your
view
and then what do you think is
appropriate for a man to start dating
again
i feel like what's appropriate like i
feel like once you're out of the
relationship like but i do think you
need to give yourself time to heal
so like do you think women do that
i i have a hard time believing we do
like
no i think we just jump into new things
i
like my alone time that's been my thing
and it's it's too it's to a fault
because i then i end up going all uh
i'm you like right now and it's like i
don't talk to people on a daily basis
and i don't know how to reach out i
don't know how to text so it's not a
good thing but i think
a lot of women have backup plans most of
the time
but i also think guys do too
and people want to say that they don't
well i think the women's backup plans
are attainable where a lot of times the
guys aren't
no no well in my experience but you also
dated you know high value matt oh sorry
hi earners
okay no you know they all were they all
were different they were all good men
i'm trying to think what was i gonna
look at
what were you saying before
i don't remember not even a word
um i was talking about yes oh the
appropriate amount of time oh i was
gonna look up okay don't look don't look
okay
what time is it
um
cvs
okay this is how i found out
my boyfriend was cheating on me
you ready shout out
now mind you
this man thought i was having sex with a
jockey do you know what a jockey is like
you know when people bet on horses
so there's a jockey that's who's riding
the horse short men like below average
and he thought i was [ __ ] them in the
barn and i walked outside of work you
saw me clock out and i was with a girl
and he's like you were cheating on me i
was like i didn't even come from the
barn hollywood my gps why is it wrong
like yeah so and then this happened the
night later and he called me from the
hospital here it's not funny
but karma's bench
huh it's gonna load it's a it's a video
so he got into a car accident with
another girl
and i was all over the news
because he's a compulsive liar no
offense jay but um
i didn't believe him at first i thought
he wanted sympathy and so he was i was
in the hospital room
because he told me i remember i i was
like go talk to her go the girl in the
article why don't you call her blah blah
and he was saying that it was his cousin
dude
now whenever a guy says it's my cousin
i'm like you're [ __ ] lying
i think they're lying not actually but
like
so for i was at his hospital bed while
he had like five gunshot wounds
literally and i was there being the
best
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
because i was a shitty girlfriend
throughout to be honest i was so mean
but
yeah
what's the worst way you found out you
were cheated on
i forgot where i was going with this
but it's alumni um i never actually
caught a guy um cheating on me have you
cheated no i've never cheated have you
entertained other men no
show me your phone i want you to type in
this date
i want you to type in
august 14th august were you guys still
together i think we might have been
broken up then actually i won't say
anything on camera no but i'm a call cap
on that for sure you're too friendly
august 14th um no you could look um i'm
just trying to remember what dates we
broke up
because it was right before i left for
england so maybe
you were i was on fresh and fit early it
might have been early september but
i actually don't really dm that many
people
um like most of these are about collabs
yeah so
like i don't even i meant your text
messages
i'm [ __ ] no you know what go to your
venmo i want to see august 14th that's
what i would do with the guy
i'm kidding you don't have to but i
would have to highly disagree you got a
lot of dms no i don't actually i don't
get as many as you think i don't either
like people always think i do i don't no
i really i could even show you my dm
requests like yeah let's see yeah
they're those are are they like spammy
they're always bothered but i [ __ ]
hate the box if anyone messages me they
usually like don't have a profile so oh
great
they're your trolls or they're messaging
me about my ex-boyfriend like this video
so like this one what am i gonna like dm
this guy with a private profile and a
childhood picture like no
why not who knows it's your soul mate
i'm kidding
yeah so it's just what's your go to your
message wait that was
it that was it on your message request
oh there is
those are my favorite to read dude
i didn't i don't even see this spammy i
don't know the because i go to all of
you haven't replied to a lot of people
yes i don't you reply so then
well that's what i always say i don't
get that many dms and then i was
thinking i don't open that many dms
there's a difference actually guys i
i want to know this put this in the chat
as men can you see the bottom of your
dms like is there an ending because
hours don't end you know what i'm saying
like what does it look like
there's
put in the chat
i don't save numbers either no no i'm
saying like so this is like this week
right i like do not text people that's
february dude you you do though like
look at mine no no
i'm gonna show you 326 okay that's open
that many unopened messages dude i used
to have thousands
look at all the blue you see all the
blue why are you open because i have a
problem i'm avoiding in nature now you
guys know want to see something worse
i'm just kidding i was gonna say my
emails but that's not that bad
um i'm telling rolo
to you
you're telling rolando i don't know i
don't i can't keep up oh is that that's
a comment
let me see your phone
she was shocked
whatever guys we all get shocked
come on
a little heart attack
did he ever put a tracker on your card
do you know how to check
once my mom did that to me
she's good my wait did she just track
your miles or was she tracking with the
location yeah
genius you go jen i was 24 too i was
like mom i'm too old for this
okay that's kind of weird jen it was i'm
not saying it's right or wrong because
when i got back with him
i didn't tell my parents at first no one
does and i was like how
how does my mom know
and she so she had my car location why
does she care though what did he do he
did something that your mom doesn't like
him
dude if you're you're a mom like from
what i hear your mom is such a genuine
mm-hmm like loves everybody if you piss
off your mom it's like pissing off
mother teresa um no he
he oh my god that was just a very like
toxic i guess like we would break up all
the time like we broke he broke up with
me
twice
and then like would want to get back
with me like the next day and i would i
would just like he's like getting guys
why do guys what would you describe that
guy as and then like
the this last time is the first time i
broke up with him
yeah and you actually like stuck to it
yeah
yeah it's hard but he literally broke up
with me like three times but did you
actually think he was dumping you or
he's trying to do it for attention um
[Music]
what do you think no i thought it was
real every time i like i'm not used to
why not
emotional men well i just would never
think you would dump someone for
attention or just for a day like that
was new to me i don't know they cheated
what they could have cheated justifies
it not saying that like don't be sad who
cares no i i will you gotta have that
mindset girl i'm gonna get it into you
who cares
who cares well at this point like i
really right yeah and honestly those
type of men like the one that i was
showing you on the google
they needed attention and some people
just can't give that to them because
they can't give it to themselves like
it's never full it's not your fault
you could have been a horrible match for
him you could have well i'm anxious so i
think that's pretty bad with fearful
avoidance because we we have like a
tendency to people please and like give
up all our boundaries pretty easily and
that's all that's like that's what i
learned in this last relationship is
that i
give up i'm really easy to control which
can be a good thing and a bad thing like
i bosses always like me because i'm
really easy like i'll give up control
easily i don't really care what we do or
like
but like the wrong person getting all
that control like
they'll take advantage when you submit
to the wrong man yeah but i'm very much
i'm very much like i feel like you have
good boundaries
oh no i didn't not in that relationship
i stopped doing everything i liked doing
like i stopped playing guitar i stopped
seeing my friends i stopped seeing my
family because i was just so like
consumed in it now when you say that was
it because he didn't want you to go were
they bad influences or did you have like
an apathy you didn't want to play
anymore like you were depressed oh no it
was more like
draining
your face
it was more like um
he just
i you know i still care about him so i'm
trying to like oh that's fine just talk
[ __ ] we don't know
but we it looks worse like honestly no
no i like he's not a bad person and i
really don't know he's not he's not he's
not a bad person
um
i don't know going on social media and
talking [ __ ] about your breakup didn't
you do that or am i
am i thinking that
yeah that's why i thought you don't have
to answer no but he he um that's
attention
he what am i thinking he basically like
sucked the life out of him
i don't want to say suck the life out of
me it's more like how i put it
he just
he he was a social media influencer so
he just wanted he he didn't really do
much like
it was weird to see someone make so much
money doing nothing
so he just wanted to hang out big
he posted a video he got a million
followers in a day what did he post an
angry reaction like
so he had a million followers in a day
so he didn't you know does he look funny
when he said great when what does he
look funny when he's angry that's
embarrassing
you should be scared enough no no it was
but he um
you saw yeah so he just required like so
much of my time and just always wanted
to like hang out that i
instead of you know sticking to a
boundary which isn't necessarily his
fault you know because i i agreed to it
and everything that i did i agreed to
but i just realized like
at the end of the year like i haven't
i've barely seen my family this year
even though i'm living at home i barely
i don't have any friends left like i
don't play guitar i don't sing anymore i
don't do anything that i did a year ago
and you realize that like damn yeah
i was like and so when i got to england
like i started
getting kind of like myself back because
he wasn't around so i started playing
guitar again and like being more
consistent on youtube and even like all
this stuff killing it yeah yeah very
consistent guys go follow her
desperately things don't put in the gym
um but when that happened like
i don't know if that makes sense like
then i just started like to realize like
we were arguing all the time when you
find your piece it's like oh [ __ ] yeah
and we were and it's just why they keep
you isolated yeah well and it doesn't
mean like i still miss him you know but
it's just like
i
was he an alpha
an alpha that's what people are saying
he was an alpha i don't think so to be
quite honest with you i think he i would
not say he was
there's nothing more girly than being
like
i don't want to say social media
influencer but like
that combined with the need for
you to be with him 24 7. to me that
gives me weird vibes he had a snapchat
just kidding
he actually didn't have snap um but i
think it was like you know of true
dude that i think it's it's kind of like
a mix like i could see alpha and beta
traits in him to be honest i wouldn't
give him like one or the other yeah
yeah people were sick i think in a
relationship like you're bound to see a
guy's like alpha and beta side at some
point if they're allowed you
so here's the thing i know people aren't
religious
and that's okay but i do have followers
that are in the bible somewhere i
couldn't quote it for you but it says
something like we know men need to be
respected and women need to be loved
so which one comes first the man has to
show the love and then the woman
respects you in the bible so the fact
that do you follow me right now
so the fact that you weren't
willingly
respect like you would
love to respect the right guy so the
fact that you didn't
it's like you were going through the
motions because that's what you thought
was the right thing that we're women do
though we suck well we get attached
sometimes i i get very attached like if
i i feel like i can genuinely love
anybody
like i i genuinely feel like if i am
around someone enough like i can love
anybody people get opportunistic very
incorrectly
how would you define it
love yeah because the fact that you had
to say like you could do it i know what
you were getting at because people like
to say that we can't fall in love like
we are
opportunistic by nature well i think
love at first is a feeling but it
becomes a choice at some point
what are your parents what kind of
advice do your parents give because i
feel like they're good
yeah um my parents give great advice um
my dad told me
to leave that i didn't take a lot of it
um the first time he broke up with me i
think like they told me to like he's
like why would you he asked me if i was
um if i liked torture my dad
he was like he's keeps breaking
interesting he's like he keeps breaking
up with you and you keep going back you
could be a mass so kissed yeah
he's like do you like torture um
yeah because it would upset you
yeah um
i'm trying to think
my mom told me to find a guy that loves
you more than you love him which is very
opposite of what the man of sphere says
no it's not no
no in terms of the way men love
that's the way men love
i i think women
it gets a bad rap she's not wrong
women can love you guys let's just be
clear we can love you we can love what
you do for us
we can love
it
people think it's not love but here's
the thing the way that you fall in love
with a girl's smile
when you protect us you stand up for us
and do things that are masculine
we fall in love with you too it's just
different dude like i'm not you're you
talking or breathing sometimes annoys
the [ __ ] out of me
it's different
no i think that like i think i've been
in love twice and i like i would say i
was genuinely in love twice i think i
was in love
never
you don't think you've ever been in love
no i was once i'll give that
kurt pappas
yeah but we
we are like
dude we both have the mo we did at least
have horrible things just going on in
our lives and it just couldn't work
i couldn't support him because i'm
unemotional
i couldn't like he couldn't he could
support me he was better at words but i
didn't want to be talked to so we lived
up he was in another state at the time
but
he's a very uh
what we would call beta
girls can love a beta but he was the guy
every girl wanted so it's weird i don't
know i think girls he was like
i've seen girls very in love with betta
guys i think it's just when a girl gets
too experienced like she's experienced
too many alphas
your alphas are overrated yeah um well i
don't
alphas i don't really i can't say i
really meant that many maybe rolo that's
it
do you think he's alpha
yes really hundred percent
i i like him but like don't you i just
don't like
it
i
think about it both of us said we want
to marry him and not fm
what's your point that's beta you want
to marry like marry the beta after alpha
that doesn't apply okay we can't marry
him
so would you [ __ ] him probably
would would i i think he would
no
it's not really my time
have you met him no dude the way he
moves
trust me is an alpha
okay dude i was like whoa that's intense
in a very
uh peculiar way unfamiliar very
comforting i liked it good times
dude you talk to him about anything
no he's really smart and i think like
he's a really interesting guy i just
wouldn't when i think alpha would not
make a role at tomasi i know what you
mean like i get what you're saying but
then i've never met him in person maybe
that would change you should see how the
guys act around him you know he's an
alpha
well i think they respect his word
outside people that don't know him i'm
telling you dude okay i survived i would
i wouldn't vouch for him that much no i
i believe you he's an alpha now the
other people i'm just kidding
no
no actually you know what's crazy like
when i was thinking about um like
boundaries and giving up yeah i he like
because he you know he was homeless when
i first met him so i like moved him into
my parents house so he could get an id i
tell you this story
it sounds like a story i've told no so
like basically he was he was super hit a
lot of money but he was homeless and
when i met him like i remember thinking
i never met a guy that um
like i had such a lack of almost like
parents like i felt really bad because
he had no proof that he existed dude
that's a hard
thing he lost like everything but his
birth certificate that was all he had
but he couldn't get an id because he
didn't have an address i talked about
this
even if he didn't even if he had like
the money where would you mail it to
yeah and so my parents put them like on
our lease oh so that was how like and
they like moved him in for like he lived
with us for like a month
that's it
well then we got an apartment because he
wanted to get an apartment before but
gotcha gotcha so he i get it so he lived
up i guess i have lived with a guy
technically but i don't really i don't
really count that that's in my pants
and plus like we had separate rooms but
um good
i don't know if that makes sense
but i was just thinking like that was so
crazy i literally like met him and like
then moved him basically into my parents
house and look at where you guys are at
now
what do you mean you're not together
yeah so it makes me wonder
if subconsciously
the reason that you're not together is
because although he makes more money
he just doesn't move in the right frame
obviously i feel like we've established
that
i'm just ripping onto this guy i know
nothing about
no you've been so sweet about it but i
think
you're being too nice don't be nice
because he
like it wasn't like it was all bad you
know like there's times where he took me
to an nba finals game he took me like
there's a lot of like really nice dates
he took me on and like trips like i
can't
is that why you love him
no
no no what do you love him well name
stuff that you love him for other than
the cool [ __ ] i just i i walked you into
that don't worry you're fine
he's he's the funniest person i've ever
met like genuinely so funny
is he oh yeah he's so funny
okay what else name five things what
else um he's very creative
um and
um you like creative because you're
creative right mm-hmm very high energy i
really like high energy people that's
like you yes i mean we like people that
are like ourselves we do i think so yeah
that's true so but everything that you
listed had to do with
things that could benefit you
you think it benefits me i'm being
creative creative benefits because you
guys are kind of in the same
that's not a bad thing i think that gets
some misconception i don't think it's
bad i would love to date somebody in the
same uh yeah
you're trying to right
i am i'm married i'm just kidding no i'm
not trying i'm i'm not i'm not a good
the guy on the phone no
kevin ah
he lives in connecticut okay
we'll see
he's he's like you should do a virtual
date like um live that'd be funny
like on instagram i just know those
i wanna
parents me on camera every time i love
it he was also very like comforting i
would say like he was very
like when he when he was when he
was like nice he was like really nice
and very like kind
mm-hmm that's a good thing yeah i would
most people are
yeah
yeah i don't know i don't know what you
would say that wouldn't be i know
that's my point is there's nothing wrong
with it yeah every people are going to
spew it but i just want to do it before
them because if i do it then it's better
trust me no no i mean it's funny i don't
want a man's it's like i'm not saying i
don't get offended i know you don't
but it's like i when i would think or
you ask a guy what do you like about her
and they always hesitate
because the only thing they can come up
with is what she looks like
we both suck i'm not saying neither is
better
but
when you ask a guy how he fell in love
with somebody it's usually like
she had a really weird laugh no that's
not
not it actually but it's like the way
she smiled when she was prepping the
pizza
and laughed at my joke like they fall in
love with that poetic [ __ ] and you would
think that we do but no we felt safe to
some capacity
i don't know any other let's see if
there's questions in the chat right now
um
oh that was
check out uh
save a house
i always say savo what do you say when
you say
because you're from here s-a-v-o
right mm-hmm tony how would you say it
oh that was like
that they think you've hooked up with
rolo
everybody thinks so
it's okay we can move with that
agreed alpha 100
there's something alpha about being able
to connect with women that gets really
misconstrued about in the mana sphere
too i've never felt more heard than by
rolo dude literally i was like i am
that's new because most guys will be
like i'm sorry you know when you're
uncomfortable in situations and you
don't know how to like comfort somebody
oh i'm like that i i don't know i don't
know how to say are you awkward i'm like
i feel like we're very similar
we have to be we're in this we're in
this space i think you're the the
anxious lover and i'm the one that you
would never date but like we get each
other like i'm
[ __ ] horrible
i wouldn't answer you for three days
because i'm doing a project type thing
but i'm thinking about you
but i don't have the energy to text the
torah oh i was thinking i was like did
you not answer me for three days i'd
even noticed okay see we're good
um but
what was i oh rolo just really
understands women and has a way of just
i felt hard in a moment where i've never
so maybe it's biased with that but i
don't know i feel like a lot of women
that didn't even know who he was you
know they were like oh
he's
protector felt very safe with him zooby
and who else was there when we were
outside i forgot fresh i think i don't
know
okay let's see what they ask women don't
respect genuine love it dries her up
that just didn't make sense women don't
respect genuine love always saying like
beta
beta traits your definition of genuine
love
is different than ours
so let's break that down
let's break that down women don't risk
women don't respect men
that don't have a frame i think it's
like boundaries for women go ahead what
is frame frame is the way you hold
yourself
the the way that
so
you know how we at least myself i can
admit this you kind of push guys
subconsciously
oh i'm going to be ten minutes late and
it's literally to us we're just gonna be
ten minutes late like we don't think
we're testing them like most men think
however
the stronger
hear me out the stronger
goal posts you have as a man
like no i don't like doing that i don't
i we can't we'll reschedule if you're
going to be 10 minutes late the stronger
they have their goal post in the ground
this is my analogy
the better because a woman is always
going to try to push those gold goal
posts is that helping you kind of think
of like the way that you keep your frame
you can't just uh okay i'll let her do
it or oh okay like we're gonna try to
move it no matter what so frame to me is
the way that's like
it
it's boundaries for women that's the
best way i can put it because i'm not
good with words frame is the way that
you carry yourself stoicism it's so many
things the one interesting thing about
the manosphere is i feel like
i i try not to say i feel like anymore
because they make fun of you
it's okay
it's okay
um but i'll do it too a lot of guys
will be
oddly like stern about random things
trying syrian men
i don't know how to describe it but it's
like they'll be it's like awkward
like like they'll you'll
do something like kidding
and like they're trying to establish
frame but it's not natural it might be
for them what it might be for them some
guys i've noticed at least there's a lot
of assyrian guys that work in the club
and they're usually the bouncers and
stuff and
you can tell
it's it's a very fine line of
controlling
we tend to think of it like that but
think about why we think that
feminism
is it wrong for them to
what if they're just trying to keep you
safe no no i'm talking about random
things like what
try to think of god i just remember
feeling like this when i was on like the
fresh and fit podcast because it would
be random little things about the studio
what about like
i still haven't watched your episode and
i have to i can't that's the problem i
can't think of a specific example i just
remember how i just remember looking at
them being like you guys are weird like
it's something like
if you're it was it was the
their their like bouncer guy
the club analogy needs to go because
guys the way that clubs run is on the
business uh structure that women are not
gonna ever pay
and they're not gonna pay because they
need to fill the room with guys that
will
let's make that clear
it doesn't
the ugly girl doesn't get in listen okay
most of them [ __ ] get in dude
seriously it's the dudes that don't so
whenever they give the anybody gives the
club analogy i'm like that one's not
fair because that's the business
structure
of course women are getting in you know
what i'm saying but um
you're saying that they were too stern
like it would be okay an example i could
think of is being stern over something
random that like doesn't matter like
what do you think um
i'm sure i could think of some but i'll
shut up i cannot think of one right now
i know because you're on the spot look
at your phone
google something it'll
i'll look at the chats while you think
try to find something that
they whether it's them or they say in
the mana sphere that um
like you could see where there's two
sides is that what you're saying like
there shouldn't be
no hold up hold on let me think okay
i'll shut up it would
oh that's interesting
i won't say it yet what do they say she
didn't like what was said it's how it
was said yeah did you read it yeah yeah
yeah
and it's i do like i do think tone i
don't know why we act like tone doesn't
matter
even as a guy your tone does matter so
for women it does
no i think for men it does too
if you walk into a room and you start
like screaming at someone of course like
oh that's just annoying
yeah like we can't we can't act like
energy and tone doesn't matter
so you're saying like
though
i don't think no it wasn't
i think it's
it's
how do i put it because it's not
comfortable like when he said shout out
my writing i'm like no disrespect like
the purpose of sex is not to get a woman
off like something like that
that doesn't bother me okay um what else
is he said
it's more like when they they start
tone's not fair
no no they start like ordering you
around over like weird things to like
try to get you to comply because they're
trying to like establish their frame but
before the show or no no i'm thinking of
an example that would work do you know
what i'm saying yeah so um i'm trying to
and it's almost and it's almost like
awkward
it's almost awkward oh you're i think i
got i think i have it yeah like where
it's like who would you
um that what do they ask you status
looks
and what else
status looks and money yeah
i keep thinking status is funny like you
need boom how the [ __ ] can you be well
you can be you can be a lottery winner
try to go in the lottery it doesn't make
you have status okay true but um that's
very true so it's like when oh okay i
remember so i knew i would help it was
it was when we got there and we were
sitting on like a couch
and they're like they almost accused us
of like trying to steal something from
like by the couch it was just really odd
or like when he first got there the
producer was like
saying oh um
like norm like normally we don't let him
up
and i was like okay do you want him to
go and he's like oh you can come in but
it was just like the way he does it is
like not natural and that's the only way
i can know how to describe it there's
some guys that do it and it's very
natural to them but i can just tell when
it's not natural to a guy
okay like you're saying like they accuse
him and she wait
no no
no no they didn't accuse him of stealing
they said like we couldn't
sit on like a certain couch because like
when you there is that couch that they
hold all their things at oh is that
really yeah that's right that makes
their stuff
that makes sense
didn't want people to steal this yeah
i don't i'm not thinking of a good
example i just i just genuinely i want
you to take your time because i know
there's something yeah and i agree with
you and i can't think of it it means
yeah it's just like a feeling when i
know that they're gonna roast me for
saying this but it's like when a guy is
clearly they won't roast you
i swear when they clearly
are just like awkwardly
trying to control a situation
like because they want to establish
frame and maybe you have to be bad at it
but if you didn't know what frame was in
the beginning
are you saying after i've like explained
it like you're
that's what you think like i'm confused
yeah okay okay i'm saying like
established frame like now that you've
explained it maybe you have masculine
traits why don't you just submit
why don't i just submit i probably do
have masculine traits we all we all have
a mix of both yeah i would say i
probably do there's something about it
that maybe you don't want to submit to
his ass so you know what i'm saying like
he does
that's the weird thing about the man of
sphere they think you should just listen
to any guy no they don't think that i
don't think no you submit to the right
dude the problem no no submitting to the
wrong ones
it's really bothering me i can't think
of it right now
take your time honestly i talk a lot and
i confuse the [ __ ]
maybe look at the chat on your phone
maybe i haven't looked at it so
um
triple x tori was on with rolo she was
next to him
confidence is quiet insecurity is loud
ah i don't know sometimes i'm loud as
[ __ ] and i'm very confident
you know
i won't be all up in your face about it
but i certainly
like what you guys call yeah he's trying
to be tough that's yeah okay um guys can
you think of an instance for us because
it's kind of when you're behind the
camera you forget it's a thing yeah um
surely you're taking
the piss i don't know what this means
i can understand it from a podcast
standpoint having to handle all the
[ __ ] okay
but
you know what i don't i'm not going to
speak yeah that's what i mean like
microsoft can control room better than
um
in a certain call manner women know what
actual dominance is i think they allow
the girls to act out for the
entertainment so the girls are obviously
going to be annoying where the guys no
they don't they check them all the time
but that's what i'm saying is they allow
them to have you ever watched how he
speaks he lets them speak
so long i'm like myron cut her off but
he does that on purpose i can tell it's
for entertainment so then when he does
come in
i don't know maybe i just see it like
of course the other guest is not going
to but they let him talk and disrespect
them and then they try to establish
frame you can't do that
so i think it's that's for different
reasons i don't know guys what do you
think
i think it's if you're gonna let a [ __ ]
just keep talking
you know like of course she's going to
disrespect you
what are you thinking
i mean if i'm thinking i'm thinking when
i was on their show i would
i would ask
myron a question and like he would go on
like the longest tangent and like half
the time like didn't even answer what i
asked
yeah we do that too oh no we do but we
always get called out
i just remember feel like thinking that
he interrupted guests oh well it says
yeah of course i [ __ ] suck at it and
he just wants to [ __ ] okay let's be fair
i'm really bad i've had call-in shows oh
my god i can't control them have you
like i can't they just keep going and
i'm too nice
myself included dude like a match like
they gotta speed it up i can't even get
through i listened to everything on 2x
everything in the man of spheres i
started
i can't listen to things without a
chipmunk voice anymore i can't do it
okay
uh hold on
and you know what like
i'm not i'm not gonna stick up for has
has nobody given you a donation guys
there's 35 people in here oh not one of
you well i just started getting them i
honestly didn't know we got one five
dollars boo yeah yeah okay guys tip me
for my troubles thank you
so i can buy my dad a home
no but it it's not about that i i'm
making good uh revenue money yeah
hello i've already surpassed it i think
like literally it's only been a couple
days oh yeah yeah but i put them on
everything everybody's been very
respectful about it because you know how
annoying ads are
like and everybody's like hell yeah she
got ads how many do you put on like the
whole thing baby like i haven't been
working i had an accident oh my god how
much have you made
so far almost i've almost hit the
threshold just with it for the threshold
of what
the 100 that you have to make before it
deposits
oh just on ads oh okay it's pretty good
what no that is good for this many
subscribers
maybe i should add more ads to my videos
i don't put that money in why
um
i would
here's the thing
charge your worth baby
they're gonna skip them
and if they don't well i do you have a
website i put the audio versions where
you can listen to it while you do other
shows no i've never done that yeah you
guys can find me on apple google play
spotify
my website torsha
it's a good way to do it and then if
people respect you which i'm sure they
do you have a large following they'll
respect the ad hustle
it's different i don't know okay guys
more ads coming soon
sorry
uh
i don't know how to pronounce this thank
you
yucca man
for the there you go the five dollar
super chat but there's no question
what was that
don't invite her oh i thought you were
talking about pearl oh no they're
talking about no they're talking about
fresh but they're talking about us when
they say that when you guys say the 304s
i'm like you guys that that we slept
with myron to get on the show is not
what happened i will be the first one to
tell you that trust me i know the whole
thing that happened but to say that
every single girl does that dude stop it
maybe a thousand body count is real
dad
bro if they did that to get every girl
in the show they would have a million
stds oh my god
it's
zero judgment just where do they have
the time
you know what i'm like that's a lot of
[ __ ] for one day
okay
plus i don't
i don't see this is the thing when i say
i have low self-esteem
i'm like
i'm like i'm like literally i don't
think they'd want to [ __ ]
listen a guy would put a
his dick in a hole or in a rock if it
had a hole no disrespect i mean that
with a lot that's i
okay there have been so many times where
there's guys that i think are out of my
league so i don't even try and years
later i find out they're interested i
was like oh my god i thought you were
show me
show me someone yeah um okay i just
i
um i don't know i think i go for
men in my league
um
like if we would qualify the uh they
weren't that good looking
the only people i genuinely desire
are hot
but that's like
i still need to like meet you
oh dang she hasn't read
um let me see if he's on facebook
he's [ __ ] a chad be honest um have you
ever had sex with a white guy
uh yes
and
her face
this was the guy i thought was out of my
league
um
he's not he doesn't
guys don't take good pictures they need
help let me
i'm a bartender i can figure this out
okay how tall is he
six something three i would say
did you hook up with him no
no i wouldn't i'll tell you right now he
has a large schlong i bet you a billion
dollars i'm kidding i have no idea um
you should show it to them and see what
they think
guys no i don't i don't want them to
because he's he
i don't think he's out of your league
i i think that's i think that's even
yeah he's got the height i i don't know
i just genuinely thought he was out of
my league so i never tried and then like
years later i found out he was
interested now he is a girlfriend so
that's why i'm not trying to show it i
think you're at last act never mind
hi
i'm a girls girl but you know oh
i
you have a thing for for chocolate
no i do but i also likes tall skinny
white boys
that's my two every girl does
they just want to admit it
so i always do short guys i if one guy
that was six children if i was short i
would totally go for short guys
like there's less girls trying to yeah
you get that because you're tall yeah i
wish
no i love being tall i wouldn't change
that yeah but i wish
that like guys were two more guys
because then you would feel more
feminine and like comfortable because
you want somebody that's your height or
taller right i think every girl who says
anything other than that is line like i
want somebody my height
a little bit if he's a jockey fine i'll
take shorter if he's a jockey i always
say i'm five eleven and a half i'd say
five ten or taller yeah yeah like dude
that's fair because you aren't wearing
heels right i have to wear heels
i do i just don't care you shouldn't
because it looks like you look like a
model next to them it's always like a
really short short designer but he's not
and like leaves the tall men to the tall
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying though yeah i
have the tall gene i'm just a mutant i
don't know why i came out short yeah but
look at my arm span it's probably the
same as you
um prop
i don't know look at it no no way no way
hold on
here stand up no i'm gonna do it from
behind now go hard wait like this okay
okay
hey
yeah that's very tall for your body
i know i look like an orangutan
oh god
i'm so small like you're so tall that's
actually crazy how tall are you five
three wow and everybody is six two or
something in my family you know the
crazy thing is i have long arms like i
i'm six foot i've had multiple girls
that are like six three that i out could
reach that's thank you for making me
feel more insecure i hate my arms that's
the thing about short men though like if
we hold hands i have to pretend like i
walk slow because these arms
if we're holding hands like this my arms
are way too long to reach them i hate it
so i dangle in the back you know
whatever but it is what it is and i was
the only baby that wasn't um ivf so it's
so strange you would think i would come
out the strongest
out of your siblings yeah okay they were
all ivf yeah they're all athletes too
huh yeah here i am with the weenie arms
anyways moving on okay did we come up
we're moving on from prussian fit
they're old news
got boxer arms i do i'm very good at
boxing because i have
like a guy has to get or a girl has to
get very close to me to knock me out
i can be literally where you are right
now i knock you out
like it's crazy
but um
take that back fine-tune gaming take
that back
okay oh my gosh i was watching this
torsha is super short
i really am people like think i'm so
tall
i'm like no can i dunk no way
i can
dude i can do so many things with these
people think i'm such a i do flare
bartending where you throw [ __ ] and
people think i'm a wizard the only
reason why it's easy for me is because
i'm catching everything way before
it looks like it but i drag it down so
funny
what else can i do with these arms
a lot
nothing fun i don't know any questions
in the chat
guys keep your girls off only fans
they hate us okay
mo i know a lot of guys that love tall
girls that are short oh my gosh no short
guys love tall girls i've had yeah i'm
actually in college i think that's the
most i got hit on with short guys
i loved that keep doing that man
i mean it was
a no for me really
is it
i mean if they're 5 10 or taller i know
like five tons average isn't it or no
it's five nine three five nine i i try
to
tony what's the average height for men
average height
four men in we're doing illinois
i think that's fair we got a lot of
basketball players
is five seven ab
five nine okay
sick
here's the thing guys
we'll end on this
if i am short
but everyone
in my family is a giant
that's why i'm like googling
what are the chances
that i have a tall kid
did i forget the husband whatever
how does like that work out can short
parents have a tall child
i'm so hungry
yes
uh
tony do you know about this
i feel like you would know
yeah but like so if i have
i have red hair right
i have the dominant recessive trait
because i have a mother
if i meet a man
they would have to
have the
same redhead gene in order for us to
actually have a baby butt
that has red hair but what can happen is
my dominant recessive just passes down
so it skips a generation
so it's like when it comes to
height
how the [ __ ] does that work
is it still the table
you know the table i'm talking about
like
i don't i don't i don't know
is everybody tall in your family my
dad's 5 11. my mom's also five eleven um
so it makes you really tall and well i
think it's because my mom's side she's
like one of the shorter ones
and my dad's so they're giants um my
brothers are all
over six foot um i think they're
my biological brothers six four six
three six
three or two maybe um
so you're just used to chinese are
adopted so that doesn't exactly um but
they're the girls
mary's adopted um i'm six foot
gabrielle's like five ten eva is five
nine amelia's
still growing but i'd say like five ten
damn dude if i ever got like locked in
an elevator or just something like you
guys would be the ones i want to be with
just like
leave frog
lift me up
son because i'm short but these arms
baby i could reach my destination with a
little help
so it sounds like it just adds it's not
like
that's such a dumb way to put it but
it's like your height if you are have
tall parents
then
you're gonna have very tall kids yeah i
have to marry someone
oh my gosh i think the perfect height
this is obviously this is going to be a
very small percentage of the population
it's actually not
the calculator is wrong really no the
height i'm going to say is very small i
think like six seven
is like that's like the perfect time
okay so she's an athlete let's just make
that clear yeah a lot of athletes
mate with other athletes athletic women
tall women if they're smart okay you
want to have the child prodigies
other athletes they they it's a thing
you're surrounded by athletes like
you're you're a professional semi-pro
whatever you want to call it i know but
like that's who you're around yeah
that's the girls are gonna find the guys
that are tall so this is different for
her dude well i said that's just ideal
like your ideal could be a supermodel it
doesn't mean you're gonna get it you
know like it's not the end of the world
if i don't get every like every single
trait that i'm looking for who cares
like i'm not perfect i can't expect him
right like dude
i used to think i was i was like damn i
was like [ __ ] you got some [ __ ]
that's some [ __ ]
but okay so name
your list obviously you're not going to
be saying
long ass thing
oh that i would look for in a guy
um like let's say you hit the wall
you got 30 days 30 days um
taller than me
or like taller like 5 10 or taller i'm
ideally taller than me yeah um
you think you could do it in 30 days
like for me i don't yeah i would go i
work hard so if i really want to get
something done like i'll figure it out
open up tinder right now
let's see if we can find it um taller
than me same politics that's really
important i used to think it wasn't but
now i see it yeah same politics um
i used to say same religion but i think
he just has to be christian or catholic
i want my kids to be raised in a church
so it has to be christian or catholic
i'd be fine with either um
i i it'd be a bonus point if it was
catholic just because really yeah i grew
up catholic but i go to christians me
too
what yeah shut up okay i don't talk
about religion on here but no [ __ ] yeah
it's just i i hate catholic ceremonies
but i really
but i really enjoyed catholic school so
that's why i got kicked out for real
where'd you go i went to uh saint
norbert's oh no way apparently my
parents didn't pay i'm like you have to
pay
what is it ccd is that what it is i
didn't i never i'd had a communion but i
never got the com what is that so
religion politics taller than me and
she's like i don't care
i was in eighth grade oh ccd it was cc
yeah okay yeah keep going uh i'm trying
to think of the other i feel like oh and
he has to work hard and i know people
will say that's money but it's not money
i know you would get annoyed if they
were on the couch playing video games
like you want them to have a hobby or
something it's just like working i think
it's so important to me i grew up with a
dad that just worked so incredibly hard
um and it's not about money i could
marry a coach if a coach worked like he
really was passionate about what he did
and he worked hard like coaches don't
make a lot of money
no but they
you know what like i would i would marry
a coach it's so hot i had a really good
quote for coaches or a plum like i mean
plumbers
they make good money but like i would
marry a plumber
yeah my dad was in traits um
and i really high energy is a bonus if
they're just like energy i really like
high energy people me too so that's a
bonus if they're just like
high energy i like want to do things
you know what i mean yeah i just wanted
someone to take me kayaking
it's like it's a running joke on my
channel
i
i've been fortunate that every date that
you that they ask me i get to pick
oh yeah
well what about you what's your list
what's your list that's pretty much mine
that's it
taller than me um
i can't think of anything else like
taller than me works hard same politics
same religion what if he was
wait your ex didn't really work hard for
what he got
um
yeah no i know that's it drove me crazy
i really like it like it drove me insane
isn't that the worst like it drove me
it's like why are crazy when people are
famous for like like
whatever status is still cool whatever
what what's my list yeah
no but everybody always wants to know
it could change tomorrow
my [ __ ] woman
at this moment
you have a salary he has to make
i always say 70k and i get ripped a new
[ __ ]
after doesn't matter how old he is like
would you because you're i want babies
no i know they can't be old i don't want
the weird sperm
cementing yeah how what's your age range
because i say i'm 25 i'd go up to 40 i
think
what about you
you're 26 right yeah i hit the wall no
i'm kidding
i'm 27 at the end of january it's not
the wall apparently
everybody i don't know uh
i want
i don't care it like doesn't come to my
head but
i always thought i was weird because i
went for older guys
and
i envied girls that would have the
boyfriends that were like just becoming
barren like i don't want somebody you
know what actually i take that bag i
want somebody that knows how shitty life
is that it's not like an entrepreneur
hear me out the amount of times i've
been pitched at the bar for their new
businesses okay you know i want somebody
that's realistic i want somebody that's
like
i'm depressed as [ __ ]
i'm gonna get out of it but like they
just get like what what age
i would like what's the oldest you would
the oldest yeah you're what's your
tinder age range or band i don't i don't
use those you gotta show me tinder and
let me see what they look like i don't
have a tinder i don't have hinge hinge
well not i did not anymore but um hinge
i think is the most like
least you know hook uppy like i think
it's more i think now i wouldn't go
older than to be honest with you i
wouldn't go older than like five years
five or six really and yeah
okay i want like babies i've always
wanted you to get babies from a guy
that's older now no i don't want their
[ __ ] up sperm
their sperms [ __ ] up the older they
are that you guys got an expiration date
too don't get it twisted
yes they do
it's it's getting i've talked about this
it's getting closer a woman still loses
majority of her eggs like let's say
hello camera let's say like
here she has all of her eggs and then
like she's about to be out a guy's sperm
it's like okay she's about to be out
here right he's only got a little bit
ahead
till like he's only out
being outward
healthier than the woman for only a
couple years
and to be honest i haven't seen much of
a difference in guys from like 40 to 43
right
i don't know i think after the age of 45
is where 50 they still look good dude
i've seen really hot 50 year olds
but
i want somebody that's like
my age
i mean i think that's as much as the man
of sphere says it's not i think that's
the preference i think i should have
been i should have did that when i was
younger
not you know why actually i take that
back
all the men that i've dated have been
great and they could have [ __ ] me up
and they didn't but their age not that
they were really that much older but
like you know they had the ability to
provide the things that i looked for i
never had genuine desire okay i'm tired
of talking
do you guys have any questions
tony is there anything that we should be
looking at the chat
only 70k stop the cap they're so stupid
no offense guys what's more important
i've seen my dad's tax returns
okay and he was providing in the north
shore
like people don't understand where we're
from
we are from the rich towns dude and my
dad was the only one working
four kids
10
taxes on the house that he couldn't
afford
he struggled
but it he could provide you know what
i'm saying like we worked for our ship
but we we always had a roof over had we
never had to get evicted like none of
this [ __ ] you know it's like it's crazy
to me that you guys think that's not
good enough
like it's just wild to me
i think it's crazy when women put a
hundred thousand dollars like what does
that look like to you i only know my
dad's salary because of fafsa you know
what i'm saying
it's like stop it what about you
salary yeah
no it doesn't matter what if they don't
work at all oh i said i can't do lacy
but that's what i'm saying is that go it
correlates in that sense somewhat but
i'm saying there's some professions that
people oh yeah coach right yeah or you
know musician whatever i just um
i'm really attracted to work ethic yeah
and i know people are gonna say
discipline yeah i know people are gonna
say cat because you know obviously but i
don't i don't need it like i i don't her
parents are loaded well i don't i don't
have like people think i readily have
access to like my parents money right
now i don't but i know one day i will
inherit a good amount of money and guys
let's be clear they're not old money
they worked for us no my dad grew up on
the south side of chicago with 12
siblings like he's one of 13 my mom's
one of nine from a farm
like it's not did he ever go to jail my
dad yeah no my dad's a nerd he
doesn't mean that you couldn't have been
at the wrong place at the wrong time
no no he never wanted to he
he also grew up on a farm it's kind of
confusing because no it's not my grandpa
would like move them randomly every
couple years to like northern wisconsin
and then back to chicago and then like
northern wisconsin and your grandfather
at that uncommon
we're just hopping around
but
yeah no i i feel like
i feel like i don't know okay if you had
to pick a number is it like the height
how old how old are they because i think
it matters how old if if they're going
to be old as [ __ ] they better be right
right right like if he's 25 um i'd be
fine what like 60. 50 60 if he's my age
like i made
40. do you work
well no not now because i'm i'm doing
volleyball my master's and i do youtube
like the school the yeah i get a
scholarship like a full one no i had to
oh my god i spent and people probably
won't believe me because of my parents i
saved up a year's salary at my sales job
i i lived out somewhere i could spend
200 you don't wear makeup you're not
spending it on [ __ ] i believe it i'm
very cheap i'm very cheap i spent like
300 a month on rent i've lived with
someone from the church yes yes so i was
able to save a year's salary i believe
that yeah and i
my parents helped me a little bit with
the tuition but i paid that's what i
paid six months rent up front when i
went to england so i have to figure out
how to pay the second six months
and bartend do you think
yeah
you know i feel bad for the girls on
i've never bartended
just pretend you have count to five and
put the mixer that's it
it's all the same really seriously yeah
maybe well i'm trying to make it on
youtube to be honest i know i like i
guess if that doesn't work out but
bartending is a skill you walk in you
don't have to train really they just put
you on yeah it's sick
i feel like you have like a bartender
look though like i i don't have the
just put socks in your bras
dude we all did it
that you just you have to schmooze but
that you could do that it's just that
i'm a dick guys love to be berated at
bars so that's what i was known for like
if you were talking [ __ ] to somebody i'd
be like you have small dick energy get
the [ __ ] out of here and then they would
tip me more
like because they want to have a good
time most of them want to be entertained
but i think you would do well catering
to the men that want to
schmooze because you don't know how to
walk away
like i'm like shut up like you're
annoying no i am i do not oh god
you would be the girl that i have to go
get and pretend to show them something
on the computer
because you have no balls to be like
you're annoying
i'm kidding
i was like that at one point okay wait
so age you said maybe up to like 40
if
45 right now right now i'm 25. 30 days
30 days remember you're finding a man's
in 30 days 30 days um
i mean okay if i had to do it in 30 days
i'd probably up it to 45 i'd probably
make this really yeah because you wanna
if you have 30 days like i gotta make
the pool like who's trying to get
married in 30 days
i'm sure if you walked outside and we're
like i'm an athlete somebody [ __ ] me
someone would come out of the bushes
yeah that doesn't mean they want to
marry you
true let me rephrase
you could find an immigrant should i
take that out
actually i would think everything from
guys from i'm selling i used to say that
at the bar dude oh my god i can't even
think of a country
you're gonna find a guy in in london for
sure but you know what i heard uh shout
out to the feminine truth she reached
out to me she has a channel and she
talks about how in the uk it's like
horrible in terms of like the smv
what do you mean sexual market placement
it's like the western like it's like the
u.s it's like horrible women are more
masculine the dating pool is just shitty
well i think but a lot of sugar babies
out there it makes it better for us
if the competition's bad
no i mean like the girls
oh i see because we're marrying in 30
days you're saying like somebody will do
it wait i'm confused yeah no i'm saying
it's just the same over there as it is
here if not worse
women are entitled right but i think
it's easier for me to date like okay
because i genuinely look at myself as a
five that's that's how i see myself yeah
and i genuinely think i'm able to date
like guys
in like a higher like league almost
because
i think if you just carry yourself a
certain i'm just looking at you and like
you're not wearing makeup and you're so
hot like
like literally you can't even see like
your cute nose
every time you turn you're like i want
to see you you can't see it it's the way
that you move that you can't see you'll
never be able to see it until you watch
back it's great um
yeah it's like when you read a book
you don't know what you look like when
you're just like yeah you know no i get
you no but it's like i feel like as
girls we have more opportunity because
i've asked so many guys like what
percent of women do you think our wife's
material and they'll say five ten
percent what's a wife to you like what
do you think it is what do i think like
your mom was she wifey
i don't think she was traditional
but i think she's i think wifey is like
anyone that
wants to work hard to work with the man
to be honest if that they so whatever
his standard is so it could be weight it
could be whatever i i think you just
have to work hard to
like make a home and it doesn't always
necessarily need to be traditional some
people aren't yeah just like someone
that was going to work hard to get along
with someone
i think that's a wife
look at you
do you see me do you see what i'm saying
he's just like chilling it's like
whatever like i can see myself talking
so i know what i'm going to look like
it's kind of like a speed bump and
you're just like oh [ __ ] but anyways uh
your lighting does wonders oh my gosh oh
my god you're lighting and it's hamilton
the way you set it up dude you can do it
with anything
probably you could do it with your phone
i've done it with my phone but on tick
tock anyways was your mom
a homemaker because i thought she worked
in tech with your dad my mom worked like
her and my dad started the business
together got it so i she worked a lot
and we had nannies so my mom
she does have this are they ugly the
nannies yeah cause i want a nanny but
she better be hella ugly no they were
pretty some some were ugly some were
pretty yeah they we it was an op who
hired them
i love it it was an op hair program so
they switched every two years yeah my
neighbor had one yeah so i had op hairs
from the time of au pairs
isn't it
up here that sounds so funny from the
time i was like a baby to
like 23. where were they from mostly
germany okay cool um a couple one from
south africa one from russia one from
like
israel i think oh no we never had israel
yeah but germans are great with kids
they're because they're they're
brazilian we had a brazilian nanny
they're loving they're two they let you
do whatever you want really but germans
are still strict but they're they
they've good english
and they work hard they love black men
that's what donovan said i saw that i i
didn't i just remembered that i'm just
like that's what i think of now
um i don't when i was in germany because
i lived in germany for a couple months
um but why is that a thing i just don't
like why is why is that known what i
just thought ever see i don't see it
like that like i feel like people just
date races it's not like specific i
didn't see that i've had i grew up with
german nannies i'd never heard one of
them say they like black guys or
i never had one of them marry a black
eye or date a black guy hi so that might
have been his experience but i i
literally grew up with a german nanny
maybe it was
somebody said it maybe it was kevin
samuels i don't remember i don't know
but it's possible
i mean are there some sure sure right
but like why is that it's like
it's just so random i don't know i ain't
saying [ __ ] what
what guys drug dealer time uh oh
what does that mean
oh you got another one guys keep keep
sending the
super chat
guys my dad was scouted for the cubs
[ __ ] cubs i know that your dad's from
the south side so you're probably socks
and we're cubs fans really really big
cubs fans
my parents bought every when they won
the world series they went to every
single game flew out there i bought
every ticket what my dad he's never
drank in his life except when the cubs
won the world series he'd had his first
sip of a cider it is my juice to bring
my dad to a world series game like so
bad
that's awesome dude okay what else
what else what did somebody say anything
why is someone laughing at me i hate
when i can read like aloe torsha it's
like [ __ ] i hate sports i'm like
gonna be sad because i just you are a
semi bro
i hate this [ __ ] i dread the day i date
a guy that makes me watch sport yeah i
hate watching dude every time they're
like you want to go to a sunday thing
i'm like no is there girls there like
can we go do something else i despise it
i will make food and leave
i just leave can you cook yeah yeah i
can't
i'll teach you i can kind of i can cook
a couple things but i grew up in i've
been working in restaurants for years
dude
so
and you know
i had no one i had to cook for myself
and i was poor but i make really good
crepes like oh yeah that's my [ __ ] i
make a french toast and do you know how
to make berry sauce
like
uh like the actual
what do they call it
all you have to do is put fruit and
sugar in a pan and like it makes sauce
oh like saute yeah yeah
yeah
i just don't like fruity sauces
yeah i'm like a bananas and strawberries
kind of [ __ ] with nutella i've been
swearing so much
i can teach you any type of food you
want to make really i want to learn
sushi
i've only done that once to be fair
because raw fish like i don't like to
touch it i love raw fish i i when i'm in
there when i'm in the uk i've been doing
like five different meals i eat the same
five things over and over again i'm
trying to lose weight and that's the
most effective way because i know the
calories in each meal and i just do the
same thing and one of them i literally
take raw salmon and chop it up and put
it with rice yeah like a poke bowl
i'm just like
slimy i don't know i i don't have you
tried uh
uh cauliflower not mashed potatoes but
like sauteed with sriracha almost like
deep fried but not
you're vegetarian yeah oh wow yeah good
for you
yeah
i'm poor takes a lot of discipline
it doesn't though i told you earlier i
like
i don't get hungry because i've been
homeless so like i
i'm trained to like it's not a good
thing it's a ptsd thing too like i'm
always on high alert so you don't get
hungry i have to remind myself to eat
but um
zucchini noodles that's your [ __ ]
you gotta get a spiralizer i'm telling
you right now bikini noodles okay i
don't really like vegetables so it's my
favorite you're gonna love it you saute
it yes yes
when i get back because i'm here for
another week after i get back from
florida we should do like a youtube
video or you teach me how to cook oh my
god we shouldn't you could come to my
house we have like a nice guy i saw your
kitchen i want to go yeah you could come
i'm down dude can we yeah is are your
parents gonna be home is it weird no
they're super nice i know they seem like
it's not it's not that's why i always
tell people it's not
i i i tell people my dad's in the half
percent like just to give them context
but yeah
we are not like the snooty i just was
taught not to be in people's kitchens
oh no my mom's so laid back everyone in
my family is like i like won't go in
your fridge i'll be like go get the eggs
my mom will like
my mom's so we just have to clean up but
if we clean up my mom doesn't care i
clean us i go i'm very my mom just weird
i've never had a sink sit in my or i've
never had a dish sit in my sink i can't
do it there's something about it would
be on my mind for too long so
jen
you would love her
stuff it's very i'm not organized i'll
tell you that but like i try it's just
like i'm not either but my mom is
there's parts of me that it's like she's
an ocd [ __ ]
but she can't be here on time
that doesn't make sense okay somebody
said what trait of men is more important
tangible things height money etc
in tag intangible
good talker listener can cook
wait say that again would you prefer
somebody that has tangible traits okay
like um height money something you can
touch okay
or somebody who's smooth i don't [ __ ]
boy
the problem is it starts with height for
me anyway yeah i'm not attracted to you
if you're under a certain height people
think i'm cap when i say i don't look at
height they think i'm literally okay
yeah because you're short i'm very high
i was sure i oh my god like i think
dating is so much easier for short girls
than tall girls people think i'm very
tall and i'm like dude i'm literally you
saw me yeah i'm like thumbelina like her
tinkerbell but so i don't notice i i
would have to say tangible things for
sure because i don't i've been homeless
it's not fun and if he's homeless too
that would scare me i don't know there's
like
i'm a [ __ ] okay i can't plan right so i
didn't plan when i moved out there i
didn't have like not saying that women
can't but men told me i was nuts and
they were right i don't know i need to
be protected i [ __ ] some [ __ ] up what
about you the hype thing i guess i said
it starts we're the same it starts with
like
it's like a guy
it's like like it starts with your
weight
right like you can't
everyone has a different threshold on
what the weight is but i can't help the
fact that it starts with your height
every guy that's a true
alpha manosphere guy will never hate on
you for saying that stuff but there are
men that will say that's gold digging
it's like no the guys understand it that
are actually they understand everything
you guys go for looks like men go for
looks
we both suck like none of them are good
you can view them both horribly but wait
yeah i thought guys went for faces at
first i learned that wasn't true oh you
don't think so they go for body face
them body the way they look at you wait
body face so they look at your body then
they glance at your face it's like a two
second thought it's like what i really
yeah
i came to my own conclusion on that
emotion you know what actually the
height weight dress size thing
you know no no no
what's your dress size no no they
because i'm i'm six foot and i'm 185
pounds and the manosphere like i ca
they don't understand like it's
different when you lift weights oh so
true it's muscle way smaller don't get
me wrong i want to be 175 that's like my
goal but i do bmis all the time so i
know i'm in the right like weight you
know what i'm saying like i've got my my
muscle i'm like guys i dead lift 300
pounds i could squat 250 like can you
squat me i weigh a hundred and three oh
yeah easy that's like but i'm a [ __ ]
like i'm not a bar it's all kinda
like if you wanna like on my back it'd
be so easy like that's nothing
then i don't want to yeah i want to see
like i do for five sets of five i do two
hundred pounds on squat
so that's that's like right
was 120 and that was hard like that it
was me and you were built completely
different yeah but and i have weird
knees well there's like two types of i
feel like there's two types of girls
there's girls that have a hard time
getting muscle but they're never gonna
be fat and then there's girls that get
muscle easily but they might be fat i
think i'll be i'm i think i'm gonna blow
up like one of those
skinny fat moms
because i didn't gain weight in in
almost like an anorexic i'm not anorexic
let's just make that clear about like
you know they start to gain uh
fat where their organs are to protect
them so after pregnancy let's say they
had a history of eating disorders their
stomach gets fat but they still have
twig legs that's going to be me for sure
welcome to my ted talk
i'm gonna be
i don't know oh gosh if your thing is
gonna come out just already ready to
throw a football
already spiking no i don't imagine the
shoulders on your kid oh gosh i already
not saying that you're like broad but
like athletes
no i
yeah
no that's so true oh my gosh i am broad
though like i'm built like no you're you
if you were not muscular like if you
were not an athlete i wouldn't think
you're broad i would just think you're
tall huh
i feel like i have broad shoulders to be
honest
it's not bad like i don't
[ __ ] tank tops
okay wait i feel like there was a
question we're missing
do you see anything let's see
um
[ __ ] you okay
pearl kind of guy make up for height
with confidence
um
a couple inches like
she she said she's fine with 5 11 or 5
10. yeah yeah like is he talking so
maybe maybe maybe if he was five nine
like fine but you know i don't even
really meet men that much that are
my height
like
i want to though like my neck hurts i'm
not trying to look up i mean honestly
though you
like you don't even have to be that tall
this guy you just have to be taller than
or taller than the girl the average girl
is five five
is it i thought it was like five seven
no it's five five oh my god i think it
might be i think it might be five four
to be honest oh my god not weird no well
my arm's still alive
but so if the average the average guy is
five nine so even if you guys five seven
like there are girls that are five one
five two five three
four eleven yeah
stay away from those [ __ ] they're
crying i'm kidding okay
is there any i don't know if there's
wait
okay torsha torsha torsha ah
does wait you were gonna say something
about the measurements yourself the
dress size
oh it should help even if it makes me
mad though because girls with my same
weight will be so fat and same dress
shows and i'm like i'm not
when you talk to him what did he say did
he think it was heavy kevin yeah oh no
because when i went on a show about but
he didn't ask me my weight or dress i
thought that you
um like i just went on a show oh yeah
okay i didn't know it was like on air
yeah it was um
no it was back in
because he asked me because at the time
i was dating juanit
he just asked me about that oh that was
[ __ ]
so people like i didn't know like
guys this cool [ __ ] is just sitting
here right now in my studio well it's
easy to call and do [ __ ] you could you
could be on a show tomorrow if you
called in it's not hard
is it not i feel like there's so many
people i don't know what i would say
i don't know what i want help with i
don't have questions they scare me i
wouldn't
i'm really i was so nervous i was like
oh my god please please don't
i would just be like
never mind i would like [ __ ] with them
in a good way be like what's up
like an annoying i bet you my dad thinks
i'm at my ex's house
you want me to send a selfie
okay
um i just think it's funny like i know
how my dad thinks that's probably i love
how it's a tape measure to check a
dude's height no this is what you do you
go up to your door i took a picture of
you and sent it to my dad go up to your
door your front door and you put a mark
where it's six feet oh i've seen that on
tick
that's how we know
no we can just tell like we we know how
tall a guy
is next to us i love to card people at
the bar that i know are of age and i
love to ask them how tall are you
because they always lie about an inch
most models do too but that's for
agencies oh actually i do and then when
i'm on when i feel like i've made them
uncomfortable i'm just like what's your
address i love doing it it's so fun well
on a roster they put me at six one yeah
see if they do that guys yeah i knew it
the agencies always lie one to two
inches
why do you guys do that
in sports to get recruited
basically or intimidate the other team
oh my god they're all giants like we're
[ __ ] well i played with a girl that
was six five she married a guy that was
six ten oh my god they're babies i don't
wanna give birth to that like i feel bad
for her
dude that thing's gonna be bigger than
them yeah my gosh i can't even imagine
but i mean good for them
she's so pretty they're such a good
looking couple though i i always say the
tall guys should have the tall girls i
preach it all the time like leave them
alone you're 4 11. dude you look stupid
like it doesn't look good when you're
you look like
what's something elf franken no who's
really tall and really short
are we done
it died i don't know this has been going
on my computer's gonna die what are we
on doesn't say
is it still going damn how long is our
show
i mean measure the guy before a date i
just don't even think
do you swipe on guys that say they're
shorter
no if hinge so well you know guys are
usually older and they lie about their
age to be younger to get the younger
girls in their
that they want
just so you know
huh don't be surprised if they lie about
their age a couple years nothing crazy
oh yeah
you're welcome i didn't even think about
see this is why i i always give people
the benefit of the doubt and i'm very
trusting so there's this is like a way
of thinking i would never have thought
of
yeah you have to just think if you were
a guy
so you know the younger hotter tighter
if they want to get those girls you have
to be around the same age at least this
is how it was a few years ago when i
used to do the apps and stuff on
people's now i think you can say your
preference right
yeah i can filter like you i can filter
but they'll still
lie about their age to meet yeah bracket
right yeah okay i like had to think
about that i'm like that was my advice
bye
okay guys
do you have any other thoughts drop your
social media links you look so confused
at me
i'm like you're good i'm tired
i'm just getting hungry
drop your links where can people find
you
um
just pearly things on instagram and it's
just dot pearly things on instagram
and then just pearly things
all the way through on youtube and tick
tock is the same
i'm not in anything anything else
just those three
just stop purling actually my snap is
pearly thing
get rid of the snapchat
[ __ ] [ __ ] i don't think i don't guys
i don't think snapchat get rid of it
the only time you should use it is if
you want to use like the smoother camera
no i snap my friends
like i literally snap like friends of
mine i feel like it's more personal
because i get to see what's going on
throughout their day why don't you
facetime them well because they're at
work or whatever they're busy it's a
chicago thing to facetime people really
yeah and just keep them there for
company or whatever you're not looking
but like people think it's weird i don't
know so it's the same as snapchat i
don't know why like to me snapchat is so
normal like it's not
like i know people associate it with
like thoughting and cheating and
whatever but i i literally just look at
it as a way to communicate with my
friends i get that i get that and don't
get me wrong i'll i'll snap like the guy
i'm like
interested in or whatever but like it's
not
not sexually it's just like like a
picture of me like like sitting and like
doing something or like i'll snap oh i'm
not i'll never respect you on it i'll
tell you that right now
what do you mean if he finds you on
snapchat like let's say
i'm just saying let's say you meet and
you have snapchat right
right he will always have that in the
back of his head same with dating apps
for girls like
like girls could be the ones on the
dating app but the fact that you found a
guy on the dating app it's always going
to be in the back of your head is like
that's kind of weird
you might not think it get back to me
later about it
i'll let you sit with that one but trust
me if everybody wants to say get rid of
your social media you don't have to get
rid of all of it but if you're gonna get
rid of one that would be it i would if a
guy asked me to okay well i don't
i just i don't really use it that much i
just it drains the battery
like hella drains it dude
like isn't it on in the background tony
how much does it
use i had it for a minute i was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
it always drains
i would get people asking for foot pics
you know i'm done who did you add on
snapchat no one dude people would just
find me
that's the thing here's what i want to
know like how can you find me without
literally my snap avatar
do you want to see my reddit i just made
it ready but it's the same it's like
it's funny um dude if i had a dollar for
every time a man asked me for a foot
pick
we've been saying this since day one
battery are you not plugged in i'm not
we will end on here but i would be rich
i would have been able to buy my tits a
bbl
whatever
but you know what bartenders make more
than girls on only fans i meant to say
that to you really yeah they're stupid
i mean that with love huh yeah okay guys
i'm gonna put all of her links in the
description but because i kept her a
surprise i didn't put it in yet but i'm
gonna do that she did tell you and then
yeah so thank you so much um i'm really
bad at outros you want to say bye bye
okay bye guys
peace
[Music]